welcome everybody I got a little ditty
here in my heart today to the h3 podcast
live live only on twitch TV for slash
h3h3 productions today's episode is
sponsored by movement naturebox me
undies and of course twitch prime
subscribers like you today we have the
legendary totalbiscuit
and of course for all my ela Kleiner's
out there the only and original hula
kleiner next week I'm excited that we
have dr. disrespect here with us if you
don't know who that is he's a really
cool twitch streamer who's really
captured my attention he's a pro gamer
but he's just super entertaining
interesting guy so that should be a lot
of fun the week after that I am excited
we have Jordan Peterson right the week
after that if you guys don't who Jordan
Peterson Peterson is he is a like a
psychologist something but he's this
caller he's a scholar a really smart guy
if you guys want to know the schedule
for upcoming episodes go to our new
Twitter account at the h3 podcast and
we're gonna be posting our live
schedules there and and upcoming guests
if you guys have questions for dr.
disrespect we'll put a thread up on the
subreddit so you can put them there we
forgot that today and okay let's
introduce our guest totalbiscuit a
prolific video game critic host
commentator and legend in the video game
world he is the host of the popular
podcast dqo optional podcast on his
youtube channel and on twitch here
totalbiscuit the cynical brit i've been
a fan of this guy for a long long time
ever before I ever even made a video on
YouTube I was watching I was playing I
was obsessed with Starcraft 2 and that
was how I found out about him because he
was a shoutcaster back then those were
those were
ARC days for me as ela recalls masters
consumed my whole life but we'll talk
about that when the man himself joins us
so please if you would welcome
totalbiscuit to the podcast have a seat
god bless you thank you thanks for
joining us this is how it's supposed to
be done isn't it we want to lay down on
the couch we've got like a little there
now I know what happens in Hollywood
we're working on pitching a show and I'm
wondering I have not raped enough people
I mean so far I'm at zero right well I
mean this is oh it's a good number to be
at I'm just thinking I don't know some
more though you it's kind of thing you
need to get started on earlier okay I'm
behind I got a lot of people in
Hollywood that are just way ahead of the
curve when it comes to that absolutely
yeah actually let's just talk about that
sure why not nice and easy
yeah why does everybody rape everybody
else well you know it's a good question
well I wasn't uh raped what is it rape
what's ready what's the deal well I
wasn't almost kind of surprised but it
seems like this Harvey Weinstein thing
has really brought out a lot of dirt
right it really does like it seems like
God knows how long this has been going
on for and people calling on an open
secret but how much of an open secret
can it possibly be if this is what it
took to get people to really talk about
it it's like this is obviously been
going on for a long long goddamn time
he's been at it for decades now sounds
yeah I can't be the only one it's it's
it's completely blown my mind as I've
seen the list of women and not just like
secretaries and colleagues but like a
list the biggest celebrities female
celebrities in the world are like this
guy sexually harass me I was like oh my
god one you can never think of right
what's our lean ahead Lisa
recently about it like good lord that's
it's ridiculous and you know you even
see people like Terry Crews coming out
and saying look you know this is a
culture of this in Hollywood and it
applies to women and to men it's yeah
that's the weird one yeah I started that
Quentin Tarantino said I knew enough to
do something about it and I should have
done something and he's like that's what
a lot of people are saying noted on
something about it's like yeah and I
have to wonder like why didn't you I can
get why an aspiring actor or quest were
supposedly with him yeah a lot of stuff
it's in a way though and in a way it's
like it's refreshing I know he [ __ ] up
right but it's refreshing to see someone
being honest about like I should have
done you up yeah exactly
nobody's saying that that is that way it
shows that it's actually a [ __ ] up
situation they're like more than you
think because people know about it and
let it happen
yeah they did and you can understand it
when it comes to an aspiring actor who's
like look this is how it is this is what
I need to do to rise in the industry but
you're looking at people like Tarantino
you know the kind of people who should
be basically untouchable
yes who were in a position to do
something about it didn't you know you
got the whole whole jumps yeah that they
really are you know that complicit by
the silence if you have a if you're like
good friend and colleague is you seeing
them every once in a while like you know
acting inappropriately it's like at what
point do be like intervene it's it's a
sticky thing I think most people didn't
understand the depth of it too because I
heard anecdotes of women being like him
saying don't tell your manager
don't tell your agent don't tell anyone
about this that's like holy [ __ ] it's
great yeah some good certified rape yeah
a lot of thoughts what do you think do
you think that the power of the position
made him more rapey or do you think the
position is what he was already a rapey
guy and the position of power is what
attracted him to go there that's got
it's hard to say in it you know there's
all idea absolute power corrupts
absolutely but there's got to be
something wrong with you at some point
you know because there's got to be
plenty of people that do not do that I'd
like to say so you think like the
thinking out
of faith in humanity left by I hope so
sure you'd like to think that there are
not people that do that despite having a
position to be able to do that yeah so
you know it sounds like a guy was a
piece of [ __ ] and if once you go into a
position where he could be a piece of
[ __ ] to more people yeah and then have
other people cover his ass which is in
itself even more disgusting the fact
that he could do it for so long and so
consistently and just think that he was
gonna get away with it it's pretty
incredible well I mean for how long did
he did yeah you know he pretty much did
the culture of Hollywood enable them to
do it when you go to the UK and this
[ __ ] is one of the most disturbing the
story of Jimmy Savile Oh God who was on
face value the creepiest looking person
alive dude for an ounce he like Samuel
anoints Sabol I've said that I heard it
recently
yeah definitely jimmy savile but I mean
we all grew up knowing that guy cuz he
was on our TVs where he's creeped out by
him as a kid or did that a little bit
there's always something a little bit
off about it I mean I'm gonna pull up a
picture for those of you don't know but
this guy
well you this guy was a child
entertainer beloved by the whole country
yep and basically immediately I mean
look at this guy [ __ ] kids you know
he's beaten raped a twelve-year-old girl
during a secret satanic ritual now this
is a guy that o wore less little red
spectacles and had a giant cigar in his
mouth like it was a larger-than-life
children's entertainer and apparently he
did that and he also chanted hails that
bear might this is on the Express that's
not a tabloid like that's a real
newspaper in the UK that's something
well respected telling Jimmy Savile was
involved in a satanic child oh dear oh
dream stone that was really disturbing
it was fun while it lasted that's so
anyway as soon as this guy passed away
apparently all the sudden I was like oh
yeah that was the most evil man alive
but he never he never had no one who got
his whole life ya know what no one ever
about this
he's untouchable goddamn untouchable
yeah I was in the era of you know kids
that grew up watching that guy and we'd
never considered that apparently we're
all really bad judge as a character yeah
oh well so I want to start by talking to
you about
well I found you through my love of
Starcraft 2 and I love that you're
wearing the Starcraft 2 hat yeah there's
gonna be some one that continues to
represent that game cuz nobody else does
well I stopped watching a long long time
ago I mean I must have stopped playing
or watching it nearly it must have been
three or four years ago yeah
Elite or before we even got married so
must've been over five years ago but I
found you through my love for that game
and it's just really surreal to be
sitting with you now because I was
making videos or I was not worried yeah
you in the grand scheme of YouTube you
started relatively recently yeah there
are youtubers in the world yeah kind of
that's kind of true yeah but now I just
want to because I had kind of a falling
out with Starcraft yeah and a lot of
people did at some point I'm just
wondering like do you think that that
game was the rightful successor to brood
war and Warcraft 3 and the large like
the legacy that Blizzard had built with
like strategy competitive RTS games I
mean I think it was but I think like
Starcraft 2 is very much a 2010 game in
2017 it's the kind of thing that if they
took another look at it and took another
swing at it they probably would not have
made the game they did you know but back
then that was absolutely the right game
to make and if you go back to a brood
war in particular and you can try that
now with the remastered version you can
see how goddamn hard that game is it's
impossible basically the possible play
well and a lot of people are fond
memories of Warcraft 3 but they probably
have fond memories of the campaign
customs and playing dota and win them
all and tower defense they don't have
fond memories of playing competitive one
versus one you know and if they did
they'd know that that game was just as
hard right
oh it's it's about making a game that
has like seemingly infinite depth and
then trying to get people to continue to
play something like that in 2017 that's
really hard to do
I mean dota and lawl are still really
hard games right but they're the barrier
to entry is kind of a lot lower you just
gotta control one dude yeah make him do
a few different things you know the
whole freaking army I mean right someone
describes Starcraft recently is I think
you're the commander but you're also the
troop trainer the logistician the guy
who orders the ration packs the guy who
orders the spare underwear for the
soldiers like your everything you're
micromanaging every tiny little part of
everything in that game
and it's too much for the vast majority
of people and I don't blame people in
the slightest for that interestingly I
found Starcraft 2 to be the probably the
best spectator experience I ever had
from a he support particularly good for
that's like people maybe you've never
watched it before I think that it's a
really complicated thing but I was
liking it too this idea of kind of
watching a sports game like a field game
like football from up above right you
know you might not know what damn thing
about football but you know if that team
is on the other team side and has the
ball they're probably doing pretty damn
well right I think that's very similar
with Starcraft neither you red guy and
you blue guy you blue guys got a big
army and red guys territory and stuffs
exploding yeah you know he's probably
doing pretty well I think that's
actually surprisingly easy to understand
and then you throw a couple of good
broadcast yeah Broadcasting's scene was
great yeah it still is for the guys who
are still around you know a lot of
people went and did other things but
we've got some old-school guys who are
just very very good at their jobs you
know so is it I wonder is it the fate of
every eSport to eventually fizzle out
and be replaced by something else so
will there ever be a game that has this
long-standing stature of one of these
classic world sports I don't think it's
ever gonna happen right like there's too
many games that follow trends there's if
you look at you know the way puppy works
right now right and a huge swell of
interest in pub G and its battle royale
games they think right well there's
gonna be an eSports scene about this cuz
it's two pi even if it's a weird thing
to make an eSports game over it's too
popular too
it was like Hoth snow it's like possums
garbage for eSports it's it's like
flipping a coin and but so many people
want to watch it anyway that they made
scene out of it do you think games like
that harm though like the the overall
goal of eSports I don't think so like I
think you can watch anything
competitively as long as you having fun
watching it and people having fun
playing it then it's totally fine when
you think about eSports you think of
like everything right yeah how do you
ladies get it to be taken more seriously
I mean I think it already is
like like with overwatch League twenty
million dollar buy-in and the people
have actually bought into it from the
NFL from the NBA stuff just happened
with League few days ago where a bunch
of popular teams got kicked out because
they all agreed to do franchising for
the LCS which is the big league of
Legends League and those guys from the
NFL and the NBA buying in with millions
and millions of dollars they're taking
this stuff seriously
and even if you've got a bunch of games
that do that like it's almost you know
just like real sports you've got your
big sports and then you've got stuff
that maybe a hundred people Jewish yeah
and that's the sport and some people
still enjoy them and yeah you know four
hundred people watch Starcraft in five
years then 100 people watch soccer after
five years blush sure they're still
having fun with it right you can make a
competitive scene out of pretty much
anything you just could have people
passionate you know after the older age
of empires guys there's no French that's
incredible yeah let's still play oh that
stuff still happens I think it will be
like he'll be around forever but as to
how viable it remains as an eSport it's
gonna be depending on how much how long
the money keeps flowing in you know once
that stops then it becomes an amateur
sport because there's nothing that keeps
sure people playing full-time so do you
think that he supports are headed
generally in the right direction and
like where would you see it in the next
10 years going
I mean it's frankly the way he sports
going right now scaring the [ __ ] out of
me like especially with the with with
the LCS thing of the last few days you
know can you explain that so I've been
out of the league scene for like a few
years so it's gonna be a real layman's
explanation so if people no doubt point
out that I'm wrong on a few things but
the basic level of it is that for LCS
that a bunch of teams in there commute
what is that else something else yes of
the Maine League of Legends League right
where think the League of Legends
Championship Series like and they've got
a big world event which is going
right now we look at world champion okay
where all the teams from the different
regional LCS get together and America
losers in career wins yeah yeah but in
the case of LCS they agreed to do
franchising and a bunch of popular teams
just lost their position in the league
and a bunch of guys just came in and it
was based on decisions other than how
good they were it was based on like how
financially solvent the organization was
like guys coming from the NBA that big
money it was right there game developers
made that decision so there's a team
called immortals that has really you
know they were very successful they were
doing really well in the LCS they were
winning a lot of games they just lost
their position in the league because
apparently they have put a ton of money
into this new overwatch League which by
all accounts is a twenty million dollar
buy-in like its massive and Riot was
concerned that the immortals team is
based out of LA riot is also based out
of LA and they have a lot of investments
into overwatch and they're thinking well
we don't know exactly why they weren't
allowed into the league but there might
be concerns that they've spent too much
money somewhere like that's all fake
they see them as like investing in a
competitor they could there's been some
speculation about that because because
of their like an owl with stupid name
overwatch League they're like the team's
are not going to be named like immortals
they're going to be named after the city
they're based in and the franchise they
bought right so this is the LA franchise
for it so riots based in LA there might
be a bit uncomfortable about that but
they might also be uncomfortable about
the idea that they've just spent a bunch
of venture capital and they might not
make it back so they're thinking about
the financial solvency of this team and
the like well what if a team in our LCS
goes and solvent that's really shitty
for the LCS and if you look at that it's
like this is big businessmen and big
money taking over what was very much a
grassroots thing right and has been a
grassroots thing really up until the
last couple of years so is that is that
a good is that a natural is that a good
direction because if you look like a
tell you look at chase ball you look at
basketball whatever this is like I was
what I was watching a news report or
listening to something about like how
Americans spend their money I mean
Sports is like by the sports industry is
huge it's absolutely enormous money
right so in a way it's natural maybe
good I don't know it could be good you
know it's that money might bring
stability it's hopefully gonna bring
some mainstream recognition it's gonna
bring facilities stadiums hopefully
we'll also see a lot of the shady [ __ ]
that's been happening in these sports
last ten years disappear as a result of
pros coming in what kind of shady [ __ ]
yeah that's like the spiciest to come to
my for people who are listening who
don't know anything about eSports like I
think it's interesting just to get in
because everybody sense how sports work
kind of different and weird so much if
this the small stuff like players not
getting paid by their teams all the way
up to [ __ ] like there was a literal fake
tournament I think it was in Malaysia
for the pp SL guys love this event and
then got mugged and had their passports
right yes Oh Starcraft this happen with
Counter Strike and everything as well
and a lot of this is because these
organizations run by the scam artists
amateurs you know they're jumping tons
of Starcraft players they were brought
on two teams that just you know the guy
just disappeared I don't know I think I
can't remember the name of the
organization but there was a guy who
just vanished overnight like guy that
player was asking where's our money
where's our money he disappeared and
later it was rumored that he'd had a
heart attack and died but then there was
a photo that appeared like a year later
on on Facebook of the guy it appeared to
be just living it up in like something
it's not like cuz there's no regulation
you can any old hooks that can come in
and do whatever the hell they like
interesting so it's a mess so maybe this
will help but also you know if you've
got any ideas about growing a little you
know community support a team a
grassroots team that's going right out
the window and stuff like overwatch
League is asking for twenty million
dollars to buy in never gonna happen
anything or is it you know one guys that
are already established I wonder if like
I think like basketball and baseball and
their infancy probably went through
something probably very similar yeah but
I imagine they also had that corruption
scandals metals um that yeah also yet
well definitely
so what do you see as the greatest
hurdles and challenges facing eastwards
now but I think it's gonna come down now
to can you get enough viewership to
actually finance the amount of money
they're throwing at it right now because
they're seeing big growth of the future
they're seeing enough growth to get a
venture capitalist to throw twenty
million dollars at a team yeah there's
enough growth for an NBA owner to own a
team pay money question is which game
are they gonna invest in because right
now that's run money at the overwatch
league is that the big one right now
that's the big one they think Barry
might this hasn't even happened yet
right like they've been over the past
year trying to make this league happen
getting people to buy in buy these
franchises for different cities around
the world yeah because they believe that
people are gonna cheer for their home
team even in eSports like a really
interesting idea yeah yeah it's pretty
spicy but will it work I mean we don't I
don't know even a game that people want
to watch enough numbers to make that
money back I find it a really hard game
to watch I guess a messy I think I watch
too much color all over I felt the same
way even though I love dota I clocked
2,000 hours on it I hated it as a
spectator sports too messy yeah it took
me a while to really be able to watch
dota I had the same problem League
earlier on with leak it was super
colorful but their tone that down a bit
you know I think one of the big
challenges facing eSports is like how do
you make a game that's great to play and
competitive and strategic or do you make
a game that's good to watch and - are
those - yeah sometimes it just takes a
lot of work and Riki man when csgo first
came out it was garbage both to play and
to watch now it's so good to watch like
it's very crisp and clean you can easily
see anybody can see what's going on I
mean if you don't understand csgo you
know guy caps for dudes in the head with
a pistol great this is obvious obviously
I think that's a great existing we'll
play all these games and I don't so a
lot of times I'll sit with him and I
watch yeah I can tell you some games are
really fun to watch even if I don't it's
important that the skill is apparent yes
what - a laser has to be readily apart
and that's what's gonna make them big
you know that that's what's gonna make
the money that these guys want the kind
of level of cash flow that they need to
make this thing is overwatch
I don't think it is I think actually now
that you've said that I think
counter-strike is the only competitive
game where you can see the skill yeah
and the play
yeah I mean you know this maybe all the
stuff to some extent like rocket League
you know I think that makes sense to a
lot of people but I don't think that I
think that but spaghetti fully hit its
ceiling all right it's not gonna go
super huge but csgo still grown what
that's [ __ ] I think counter-strike is
the one game I've been around ever yep
it was the first multiplayer game I
played over the Internet yeah played on
dial-up modem and it's still I don't
know if you were sharing this experience
but I used to play on dial-up modem Oh
nobody had DSL yeah we all had like 300
ping er then all of a sudden these sons
of [ __ ] show up with like hundred 50
33.6 to a 56k modem yeah that was left
look at me I am [ __ ] amazing it's
like no it's still terrible though yeah
you could download those images are like
five or six kilobytes a second instead
of three to four and I was on [ __ ]
technology yeah so I think I think
counter-strike might be the golden child
yeah I think it is the wit that the
weird thing about counter-strike is will
a game about shooting people in the head
make it the mainstream like as an eSport
because there might be some some
opposition to that you know that's well
you look football people over things
these guys are literally killing it
right this is a virtual yes yeah I mean
you still got capping people in the head
of the desert eagle but you know it yeah
there's probably so more acceptance for
those are real people yeah I know the
problem is yeah it's when you I see what
you mean though you know it's just
general acceptance was still in a place
where people are blaming video games for
stuff right you know we still dave was
the NRA brought that up recently about
the Vegas shooting yeah sure like a 60
year old guy the reason they did that
was cause he played counters out how
they're deflecting these days the NRA
every time you know video games in real
life not envy or you can have right you
can have 50 rifles in real life but you
can't use them in video games yeah so I
recall you saying that you owned a sport
you sports area for about two years what
did you learn about eSports by owning a
team that's far expensive what do you
how like cuz it seems like a low cost
thing what cost you money so we had a
team house that was based in Seoul Korea
Seoul is not a cheap place though sure
so we needed to locate it relatively
close to the studio where these guys
were playing the global Starcraft Lake
which was the big Korean league at the
time you've got a obviously paid monthly
salary upkeep on the house so what do
you pay those guys I mean at the time it
was like you know anywhere between a
thousand to a 1/2 thousand dollars a
month like so that's it adds up though
and you have like 10 guys yeah exactly
you know you don't need that many for
like Starcraft it's not a team based
game but you need enough people together
they can practice together and be good
so like where time we had six players on
our team so that was costing a bunch of
salary alone it's not too bad to hire
them for that at that time because
they're not paying for food they're not
paying for rent you know so these are
guys who haven't gone to university yet
or a delaying university they're just
doing stuff before that military service
really right so they don't really need a
lot of money in Korea you have the
mandatory yeah mandatory mess so most
most of our guys had actually already
done it as we we had like some older
players but they were fine on that
because of course you know we gave them
107th prize money so it's very like you
know if they win 10 grand and the
tournament they're sweet you know so
where did you make my sponsors yeah we
we had a few sponsors like did we ever
break even I barely like you know I must
have tossed quarter of a million dollars
into that hole and you're broken
eventually but probably with a lot of
work that the point were you like this
yeah I mean it was a massive time sink I
mean even just booking flights and
hotels for these guys to go it's in
national tournaments bearing in mind you
dealing with people that didn't speak a
lot of English yes you know even their
passports they have their names
backwards we had God knows how many
problems with that it's like oh we can't
get on the plane because the ticket says
you know it's gonna the ordering on the
Korean passport is like something like
surname first then middle name combined
with first name or something like that
so like this isn't the same person like
it is they just write it differently
right so there was all of that crap
and or you know it adds up real quick
you know and trying to find it enough
sponsors that will pay you enough money
and then of course it comes down to a my
guys on big stages where they're getting
a lot of publicity are they're winning
and I'm often I don't know that once
it's hard to get those really good guys
cuz they got to pay a more they expect
more right and even then the best blame
at stock ref to isn't winning all his
matches you know yeah a champion often
goes into a slump like I think I'm
beyond 2016 yeah world champion he has
not won a major tournament the whole
year the thing that I noticed about
Starcraft having been in big fan the
most popular players were popular
because of their personality and not
like you had a drag these guys were not
like on Koreans
they're all gone you know because they
couldn't keep up and now it you know
there are some foreign players who've
got really good like Neeb has what has
won a Korean tournament easy the first
foreigner to do it like 11 years it was
that french guy Stefan defano
as a fan he was a party guy I mean I was
a third player he was good that's all I
cared about
he won tournaments he could beat Koreans
personality yeah like I think that's one
of the major problems we might have
right now is that a lot of those guys
retired you know and the best players
are still in career and it's hard to
give a personality to someone who
doesn't speak English you know it's
another big obstacle it's like you when
you're you're good at video games
between like 15 and 20 yeah especially
Starcraft like when you go fast like
you're gonna you have arthritis after
the game playing Terran exploding wrist
syndrome you know people used to play
there and they'd have to have wrist
surgery like aged 22 because their right
wrist would be so busted up in
basketball for example you can have
someone who's 35 years old and crushing
it right yeah but but I guess that
happens in all kinds of professions like
models they can yeah you've got an age
cap on it definitely but generally in in
sports I think people have a longer a
longer longer careers and I think that's
important to sustaining it because you
need a cult of personality you need
someone to follow
grow with right yeah like Kobe these
guys play for 20-30 years
they held people's attention for all
that time yeah it's kind of hard when
you have a guy who plays for three years
and then disappears vanishes yeah you
know like just like everyone you just
mentioned you know they don't play
anymore
it's just not the life spot on them and
even the old-school guys like a fear for
dota you know he's pretty much retired
now like he can't keep up it's yeah it's
not a viable career path for most people
like I never recommend it to anybody
right don't know all right well hey
let's take a quick break to thank our
sponsors I am gonna use the restroom and
get take care of some business but we
have got a lot of spicy interesting
stuff to talk about so please do not go
away something terrible will happen I
don't know what does that work is that
is that fine yeah and like superstition
something awful is guaranteed to happen
to you if you switch so please stay
tuned and we will be right back
thank you to movement the incredible
watchmakers oh my god
oh my god Wow elegance embodied in a
watch movement was founded on the belief
that style shouldn't break the bank the
watchmakers goal is to change the way
consumers think about fashion by
offering high-quality minimalist
products at a revolutionary price this
price is changing the world just like
George Washington did when he crossed
the Delaware this is the George
Washington of watches with over 1
million watches sold to customers in
160,000 countries around the world
movement m/v empty watches has
solidified itself as the fastest growing
company just like the United States
manifest destiny it was our destiny to
take over every plot of land in this
country from sea to sea so is it
movements destiny to completely destroy
the competition and the watch game right
EULA and please don't forget they're
also destroying the screwdriver game
look at this this is unbelievable
like we'd like to joke they're selling
adorable screwdrivers that come with
watches as accessories
listen this watch is insane I walk
around I get underwear thrown at me
people look at me I'm and I can tell I'm
like oh my god am I having a good hair
day or something and I'm like oh they're
just looking at my watch so this watch
is awesome and the price is incredible
these watches start at $95 at a
department store you're looking at four
to five hundred dollars for a comparable
watch incredible Liston movement figured
out that by selling online they were
able to cut out the middleman and retail
mark-up by providing and they provide
the best possible price they've got
classic design construction and if you
go to MVM t.com slash h3 you get 15% off
with free shipping and free returns if
you're trying to class you up your look
you need some gear go there go to nvm
t-dot-com /h so you will not be
disappointed with this wonderful
high-quality so
and also comes with a with a great
little screwdriver then like the watch
gets them to your house the screwdriver
seals the deal you're like hey baby
check out what I've got man let me see
that chastity belt Oh tinker that right
open you know what I'm saying anyway
thank you to the movement and be empty
for supporting it if you're in the
market for a watch please support help
could sit please consider supporting us
by supporting them god bless america
next up this is possibly the best copy
I've ever gotten in my and my time here
me undies friend of the show benefactors
wonderful people they make the softest
underwear socks shirts hoodies they make
it soft just like you or heart yes softy
but here's what they sew me undies makes
underwears your butt will be proud to
wear and check this out we're not the
only ones who love me undies listen to
what this sweet young man Christian had
to say they this is a note from Ryan
wait oh yeah this is Ryan sorry that's
not Christian this is Ryan
Childers an h3 listener and Mandy's fan
now this they're like here this is the
best comment that one of your fans said
just read this this is the best
endorsement for this product you can get
when I first heard Ethan reading me on
DS ad I thought it was an Irish person
trying to say me undies the undies
however after reading many online
reviews about how soft and comfortable
they were I decided to finally pull the
trigger because I wanted a pair of those
life-changing undies when I slipped on
my first glorious pair of me undies I
felt like the clouds had parted in the
sky and a beam of light illuminated
straight up my ass he actually said up
my rear end but I'm trying to dramatize
a little bit they were so comfortable
that I knew that the world would never
be the same again because of me on DS my
ass is a whole lot happier - Ethan and
yella that's me and you thank you for
doing such a great job and for always
sharing your sick memes with listeners
like me well thanks for that beating
them and I actually fully endorsed that
I mean listen I plan to have kids
someday
I got a cradle the junk with the best
possible that was a great comment by the
way yeah that was really nice mr. Ryan
or Christian that was written by Ryan
child errs so who is Christian Christian
is uh God you Jesus okay he's watching
he's a undies fan as well I rumor has it
that their robes he was crucified in
were made of modal seasoned Okamoto
that's why he came back
he's like s us Jesus Jesus listen my
friends to get 20% off the best and
softest underwear and socks you will
ever own with free shipping and a
hundred-percent satisfaction guaranteed
that means if you don't like it send it
back you get your money back go to me
undies comm /h 3 that is a meet undies
slash h3 pick up a pair you won't regret
it thank you for supporting us and
finally nature box these guys have
figured out the snack in we all eat
snacks if you look like ela and you're
skinny if you're voluptuous and thick
like me we all eat snacks we all love
snacks well guess who does it better
than anyone
nature box ok we all want to eat better
but when it comes to snack sometimes it
feels like the whole world is delicious
and a billion calories versus boring and
tasteless it doesn't have to be that way
up your snack game with nature box
they've got a hundred snacks that taste
good and are actually better for you all
the snacks are made from high
ingredients simple ingredients which
means no artificial colors flavors or
sweeteners so you can feel good about
what you're eating please you scroll
your website it's a joy starts
salivating top sellers probiotic power
mix that means it makes you I think we
spoke about that but probiotic it's like
good bacteria for your
[ __ ] mm-hmm it's powerful stuff
there's a lot of science going on about
probiotics these days they think that
that's the real cutting edge of health
I could probably step up my probiotic
game I'm surprised that dried mango is
the most popular to be frank but hey if
that's what you're into I skip right
past then go to the sriracha roasted
cashews that's my jam you try those it's
a little spicy a little sweet a little
salty forget about it okay but whatever
it is you're sure to find your new snack
obsession at naturebox
they add new snacks every month inspired
by feedback and the latest food trends
and professional chefs guys it's so
simple go to naturebox.com/tyler them
right to your goddamn door it's no risk
if you don't like it don't eat it
they'll replace it for free so listen go
right now to nature box.com slash h3 get
50% off your first order
when you go to nature box calm that's
five zero percent half off do the math
it's unbelievable nature box calm
you are not gonna regret it so thank you
to our sponsors if you're in the market
for a watch some underwear that's
comfortable as ever and some wonderful
healthy and delicious snacks consider
supporting their sponsors helps work the
show and now let us return with your boy
totalbiscuit welcome back everybody to
the h3 podcast with totalbiscuit
when i had video game donkey on last
week yeah and I asked him what does he
think the state of gaming is in and he
said he thinks it's better than it's
ever been
do you how do you feel about that do you
agree I think there's a lot of things
you can point to that will support that
opinion and then there's a bunch of
other stuff that you can point to that
says god this is getting worse like 2017
it's been such an amazing year for games
you think about like every other week
that seems to be something coming out
that's just top-notch in whether it's
triple-a or indie or somewhere in
between but on the flip side of that
you've got maybe the like most
insidiously creepy awful year
comes to companies trying to really push
the boat out in terms of how much they
can milk out of [ __ ] they put in games
that just takes you out of the
experience and interferes with it you
know you've got battlefront on the way
where they said yeah all of the
progression is in loop boxes what they
already ruined that game once but yeah
they did with the last one they've a
second time you know sad thing is the
game plays a little bit better this time
but they've ruined everything else by
saying hey yeah well let's have all
progression you know what the hell was
wrong with like quad 4 and the way the
progression worked there they gave you a
few good guns right off the bat and then
you could get some of the stuff that was
their personal preference it was fine
and now it's like well we want everyone
to get random [ __ ] through boxes no the
stuff you want no no no you've got a
you've got to get more boxes to get the
stuff you want you've got a or crafting
the next person just say craft something
video I'm just gonna strangle it's not
crafting it's a pile of [ __ ] random
ass currency that you come up with like
you're not crafting anything you're just
clicking a buck you're crafting a dollar
25 and you're wrong you know it's
crafting we've got any question from
single mom 95 that is really - this
single mom are you there and I love that
name by the way what's your question bud
so it's 4 TB first up Congrats on 10
years of mr. and mrs. Bain by the way
yeah today you're spending with my
marriage is fine anyway single mom so my
question for you sir is now that we're
seeing an increase in microtransactions
and loot boxes and paywall content what
can we do as consumers to combat this
got it's hard question thanks for the
story thank you very much thank you very
much appreciate that so you know the
first instinct of any was saying well we
should stand up
it was a boy cup things and then you
realize that makes it not a damn bit of
difference because battlefront [ __ ] as
that was so 12 million copies freakin
yeah I it's terrible that it's a really
unbelieva yes and this one will probably
sell a bunch as well and we really can't
make much of a difference in that regard
right but I'll tell you this for a fact
what shareholders and these large
companies move really really I keep
forgetting it's 7 B needs to be in my
face that yeah
what shareholders of large companies
really really don't like is a ton of
negative online publicity they don't
want to be seeing that kind of thing and
Triple A is beholden to the shareholders
so when things like the loot box
controversy around battlefront came out
you can bet your ass there's a few
shareholders EA saying why is that while
there was negative news articles about
this game you're making what is a game
on Steam have 30% like exactly you know
why are all the reviews in the toilet
for this why is on Metacritic rating
tank because of all of this stuff they
do care about that why is their
Metacritic rating only a 94 85 yeah
indeed well let's cancel bonuses of the
team let's fire the dev team as well
obviously it's like hasn't have been
happening forever where these games like
if you go to Metacritic well they always
have like 90s no matter what but the
user user reviews like on the tank they
call it meta bombing
yes the name of it just review bombing
in general as well but that's been
happening and it doesn't seem to have
just waited I think it slowed them down
like you yeah you had to make a
statement a couple of days ago
backpedaling some of the loose rock
stuff for battlefront
did they fix it now is it better than it
was yes
maybe they fix it more if there's more
pressure applied you know the problem is
you could get every like hardcore guy
that listens to this show reads all of
these forums to boycott a game and then
everyone else just goes out and buys it
anyway who is really into that [ __ ] yeah
so really all you can do is make a bunch
of noise and say look this is
unacceptable this is nonsense you know
go write a forum post about it go make a
negative review for the game if you
truly believe it actually makes a
difference like it it's depressing cuz
do you think well I can't do anything
and like you're probably right I think
it does do something I think it does
make it takes
sometimes you don't see it immediately
but maybe like within a year it does
this well I could tell you from my point
when I go and when I consider buying a
game I'll briefly look at the reviews
and if I see that I'm passing yeah and
some people will as well and it's right
when people do that and I think your
point was really valid when you said
maybe it doesn't have a night well yeah
yeah maybe the next game or maybe the
thing they do in a year's time the baby
there's a change there or who knows how
much worse it would be if people haven't
made a noise that's true you know we
might reach this point years and years
ago if people hadn't been resisting it
it sucks to be in this constant state of
feeling like your hobby is getting
ruined by some [ __ ] in a [ __ ]
boardroom and you have to constantly
yell and be angry about things it's
[ __ ] exhausting we just want to sit
down play video games man is there any
great games that are doing it right
I think this is actually more than doing
it right then are doing it wrong like
the news gets covered with all this
negativity but who's doing it great
right now I mean if you look at it say
their company the brought out help light
right like Ninja Theory they made hell
play a game that looks like it looks
incredible it's looks it looks like a
triple-a title their release is the
thing for $30 single-player only no
micro drones that hasn't snowed easy
let's call help late hell bleep go buy
that game it and it's incredible and you
think right they made that on their own
without a publisher with no [ __ ] it
got really well reviewed and it's sold
really well look at cuphead sells a
million copies in the one believed looks
so that game's really cool actually
beautiful look at stuff like that but
the thing is this stuff maybe not as
incredible as stuff like that but good
coming out every single week and there's
stuff to support there's you know go and
have a look on Steam fine so it looks
interesting give it a try you don't like
it within two hours refunding you know
give some attention if you think these
triple A's are bullshitting you go play
something by an indie because there's
tons of interesting stuff out there it's
really looking for your attention
support that so let me switch gears a
little bit because I know you've been on
YouTube you've been in eSports forever
you've been on YouTube forever - yeah
2010 was on a start on the YouTube stuff
so one of my questions is what's your
opinion on adblock I mean it's
ultimately there's a few ways to look at
it and you got to be kept very careful
about talking about adblock
because why because I think people get
really militant about it
like I think if you read read forum
threads or subreddit threads about
whenever a site has bad ads or whatever
you'll see like those building this is
why I have adblock block on YouTube I
guess I'd walk into YouTube in
particular it's like in theory the way
the system is supposed to work is it's a
free video and if it's free that means
you're the product right you as the
viewer of the product you're being your
data is being sold you are being sold to
you're not kind of our customer as a
viewer and if you add block it you're
taking that kind of out of the equation
and really if Google wasn't backing it
with infinite money YouTube would be
dead you know as a result of that I
guess that's why nobody cares and what
I've always wondered about is why do you
think that youtube doesn't stop it cuz
surely they they could I think they
could get more aggressive with it but I
think they're afraid that if they get
more aggressive with it it actually
raises awareness that ad blocking exists
like they're still very large yeah it's
like what I was saying earlier about you
know battlefront sells 12 million copies
even though hardcore were like gamers
and people in the industry know it's
[ __ ] a bunch of other people just buy
anyway like they'd rather people just
didn't know about adblock and
particularly in the mobile space right
like they make a lot of their money now
through mobile ads because ID blocking
is not prevalent right whereas like you
look at a PC audience it's very
prevalent there but it's less prevalent
I'm like you know I'm surprised frankly
by how little people still don't use it
and there is a growing number of people
I found of those who intentionally turn
adblock off on websites like to
something that's great yeah you know
it's important though it is their right
to do it you know it's not not illegal
about it and everybody finds ads
annoying what bothers me is that if
YouTube was better at directing and
targeting ads they could put [ __ ] up
there it will actually interest people
and not be a massive interference if and
if content creators don't take the piss
you know they're not mid rolling every
five minutes they're not shoving ads in
people's faces you know I think watching
a 30-second ad for a thirty minute video
is pretty damn good I'll tell you we
just got cable right
I haven't used cable in 20 years yeah
I'm watching a late night show and I
swear to [ __ ] it's an hour long and you
have commercials throughout 5-minute
long blocks of commercials then he comes
back on I was watching Jimmy Kimmel yeah
and then he does an integrated ad for
Coke coca-cola
yeah that's another two minutes long
it's just a straight-up ad sketch for
Coke and then it goes back to another
five holy fun yeah I mean I think some
Annette uses maybe don't know how good
they've got it yeah Andres shirt and I
think a reasonable amount of advertising
to keep content free on the internet is
great because I don't think that'll be a
boring stuff the right thing to do no I
think it's great that people can access
this content a lot of us have had to
resort to other ideas in other ways to
make a bit more money and that's on us
you know we're responsible for making
sure we have multiple revenue streams
and then we're you know we're building
good solid businesses we can't just rely
on one income source yeah we should get
as many as we can but I just it would be
nice if we could find a middle ground
but the problem is that involves other
websites not taking the piss when you
here's an example like I went to PC
gamers website calling them out right
there on my iPad right and the whole
screen was covered in a full screen app
that I couldn't get rid of and now I
start scrolling down the page and it
Scrolls up to another ad that covers the
whole screen yeah like it's cancerous
it's like you did this yeah I mean
that's what causes yeah and it bothers
the [ __ ] out of me YouTube is
responsible with ads as as much as a
website like that can be yeah but yeah I
mean I I mean I use adblock at home I
disable it on YouTube I do yeah and I go
up YouTube right although the best way
you know if the office service like that
that's cool you know I use that yeah I
have like I have it on one account on
the other one yeah it's no my Starcraft
account so I keep that reminds me to go
back to our main one every time I see
and I'm like what the hell up what's an
act well I guess I might my opinion on
is like it is a bit annoying I feel like
people on the Internet in general are
just so entitled to free [ __ ] no I mean
I used to it right yeah it's just like
par for the course where it's like pay
yeah watch an ad do anything to support
this person who does
for a living I mean clearly none of us
here are struggling but in general yeah
that's the difference between being able
to do this as a job and not being able
to do this is a job and yeah I think
it's it's just important to focus less
on the people that choose to adblock and
more on the people who are wouldn't
support you in another way
yeah because let's be honest you know
someone who buys a t-shirt that's worth
a lot of that's worth watching if you
buy one t-shirt that's worth watching
like 10,000 be exact you know to use
youtube bread in particular and I hope
to spread it out to more countries like
red is really good for creators we get a
big chunk of change from bread yeah and
we do really well as a result of that I
just want YouTube to make it a
worthwhile service because if I said to
someone and someone asked me is YouTube
bread worth the money I'd honestly
probably say no it's not well we're
actually one of the best marketing
things they could do and I actually do
like the product simply because I get to
stream music from it - I get Google Play
Music if you get in that service with
Amazon or iTunes Apple would cost $10 a
month they want him that's how much I
pay for read/write or is it 15 it's 10
so basically getting it for free I just
cancel iTunes or Amazon for streaming
like new albums do it there and do it I
get it all yeah I mean I used it for the
offline viewing and for the minimized
viewing the background for audio yeah
unlike my iPad or whatever that's great
for just like listening to long videos
that are basically podcast which is like
all of my videos so I think it's good
for that the more they can do to make
that service more attractive to people
the better because they could quite
literally do away with ads completely on
YouTube if the go enough people sign up
to that thing and everybody would be
doing just fine yeah totally
so your your critic obviously of many
everybody is yeah everybody's a critic I
agree I myself and critical may be
overly critical at time and there's been
a couple times you've turned your
critical eye towards me or eyes in
general it probably was some measure of
fairness as well I don't so measure of
not understanding what the [ __ ] I was
talking about well anyway well let's
strike here one one of them I think was
that you think that we were a drama
channel and so I wonder do you still do
you think that and how do you define
what a drama channel is I don't think I
do honestly not anymore anyway
it it was more of like I have an
anecdote for you right a few years ago
we went to PAX East and we got a little
hotel suite near the venue and event was
done we invited everyone over just you
know have pizza have some drinks or
stuff like that and you know we did 12
of us all use your bus we all sat down
and we watched
vapenation and we watched all of your
videos we were laughing our ass of my
wife had never seen you guys as you
walked with vapenation she was just in
tears variously funny and then you
compare that to something you know a bit
later on where you may be talking about
you know mentioning you know even
mentioning like keemstar by name is like
invoking Baltimore you know oh yeah you
saw and you see sort of a channel going
in that direction and you get a little
bit worried for them and you get if I
could said like they're crossing over to
the drama sphere and like out away from
the comedy a little bit and I think the
problem with the drama severe is that
anything feeds it right even mentioning
that it exists like feeds that
particular subset of content on YouTube
and makes it stronger and it's one of
the only kinds of concept that thrives
in negativity like that entire like what
is the only way to really get rid of it
is to kind of freeze it out completely
but I get you know the thing to note I
suppose is that the audience for that
content are really young for the most
money yeah you know like to the point
where there's not even a crossover more
from the nob between like your audience
and the kind of audience that someone
like that would get you know so I I
don't think well yeah I think you know
it also comes like a you know we talked
about in news right we talked about the
concept of important news topics that
have relevance people on YouTube
like the difference between what is news
and what is drama like what is something
that has a wide-ranging effect on the
site sure I you know what happened with
Felix for instance had some wide-ranging
repercussions for a lot of people right
yeah he's part of the reason the ad
pocalypse happened yeah there's no doubt
about that
yeah I don't blame him for the ISIS bit
but you know he certainly had a part to
play yeah in a part of that right and
then when people report on that well
that's important news but you know at
what point does it cross over it into
the territory
being drama so what are you what are you
how do you categorize drama just
basically talking about it without
adding something interesting that just
pulls in views oh my god the way that I
define it the way that I'd split the two
in his drama talks about the person
whereas news talks about an idea okay
and if you can divorce the idea from the
person in a sufficient way then as far
as I'm concerned you know that's talking
about interests the news is there is
there as that may be in some way
inherently at terms with like a comedic
take on things where sometimes you have
to do it be more you have to be more
dramatic oriented and that like you have
to talk specifically about like the
people about the people they are and
that the situation of how things tie
together because I feel I mean I think
you gotta tiptoe around that you know
it's the the concern is rewarding that
person who has been a piece of [ __ ] with
more views and more popularity by having
your platform implicitly support them
even if you don't explicitly support
them and that can that's a sort of
really sucky thing to look at and I've
looked back in stuff I've done in the
past and thought you know could I've
done that better could I talked about
this in a way that divorced that person
from the argument yeah and sometimes you
can't sometimes it is really hard to do
yeah you know I don't think you can talk
about someone like leafy without talking
about yeah yeah of course so it's it's
to his content is to tie into we could
like in that situation you could make a
video about that type of genre videos I
mean it's possible but it's interesting
to think about it like that it's just
weird because we won't you got a you
know in a way you have to give the
people what they want
yeah like you know you do you look at
like content cop for example as drama
because he is all about the person right
he is in a way because it is more
dramatic they have more watchable more
Juicy's for entertaining both right it's
funnier so would you consider that drama
or how would you divorce that do you
think he does that well I mean I think
sometimes he does yeah it's most of the
time you're right he goes straight in on
the person
he goes for the jugular and a big way
like it's vicious in many ways you know
you watch his latest one and you look at
stuff like what he did at the end you
know the diss track is comedy gold
there's no question about that and
talking about that guy as a person is
important enough itself because you're
talking about an inherently dishonest
personality who is consistently lying to
people
misleading kids scamming people
misrepresenting his life in a big way I
think you're never going to be able to
completely divorce that from Java right
but is it justified I mean probably yeah
yeah yeah the guy deserved everything he
got and then some in that I think he's a
piece of [ __ ] one of the things like
back when drama was really becoming a
thing or something that really bothered
me about leafy and some of his
contemporaries was that they didn't they
didn't care who they made a video about
right no they didn't yeah then they end
up like just [ __ ] on some random 12
yeah it is like they have no morals like
in that respect then I think maybe when
you get to that point the only approach
is to hit them back as hard if not
harder mm-hmm half of me makes me wonder
if it just the kind of person who enjoys
that would just revel in that notion you
know don't even care who's getting made
fun of even if its leafy himself how
does that help him in some way and I
don't know it's it's hard to know you
know when you have a really large
audience you've got a responsibility one
way or the other
yeah I've responsibly all of us do to
try and make the site better to try and
encourage a culture that isn't [ __ ]
horrible and to also try and make
content that is gonna make us all money
you know it's gonna make advertisers
happy but without compromising our
creative freedom that's a real [ __ ]
tricky balancing act I think one of the
problems that happens is when you have a
huge channel with a lot of influence and
they don't respect that influence yes
that can turn that can turn sour yeah I
mean you look at what [ __ ] t Martin
Crowe syndicate did right yeah I mean
that's literally scamming children with
gambling that that was basically he yeah
well they didn't they didn't I mean
there's still the cause I know I think
it was I I think it's gone I think
they've been nice fathers I know
charges there was still a civil case
going on but the FTC ruling came through
and it dropped right they didn't find
them but they did impose a bunch of
restrictions like if I don't if they
ever want to do anything sponsored ever
again they literally have to submit all
of this [ __ ] in writing to the FTC for
like ten years or some [ __ ] do it though
because they were supposed to do it from
the beginning good question well who's
gonna hold their feet to the well
hopefully after you say yeah hopefully
they pissed off the FTC enough that
they're on their radar now there's a
little guy called Tom AK did a really
good video where he analyzed the ruling
and there's actually some quite
restrictive [ __ ] that has been aimed at
both of them and you would hope that now
that the FTC has said you are gonna play
ball and you are gonna do everything by
the book that if they step out of line
if they even [ __ ] breathe wrong if
they come down on them like a tunnel I
hope so that's what you would assume to
happen from the yeah what you would hope
you know I mean but they all imagine
that they got sued for like and find
millions of movies no but that didn't
happen no I think they're totally fine
as I understand it but let's circle back
to that because I want to say there was
another issue you criticized us for
during the apocalypse yeah we were say
are we made a video talking about how
like YouTube's changing and we're gonna
have to find different ways to make
money and we can't make videos like we
used to and and generate the revenue and
I think you are you made a video saying
that we were didn't make a video yeah it
was just a soundcloud podcast where you
were saying or what was your point there
I don't know I can't remember which bit
of that that was a 45-minute [ __ ]
podcast something about that we were I
guess exact are your CPMs were good yeah
I never showed our earnings so yeah yeah
that was what it was and that was like
totally [ __ ] wrong with me to do
because it's weird to look at your own
data
think right well CPM should in theory be
fairly consistent across different
regions so if I'm looking at my data and
I'm seeing strong CPMs and I'm seeing a
good fill rate and then you've got a
channel that's bigger than
that's getting a lot more views than
mine that's getting you know very
American oriented audience which is the
biggest ad market there is in the world
yeah to see to imagine that a channel
like that could go down as far as it did
and of course now we know that they did
this D monetization [ __ ] that we didn't
know about they didn't even tell us they
would show that it was completely fine
yes yeah and only till like this month
they started showing that it was
actually not that yellow yeah but
because we I didn't know about that
nobody did this is a real [ __ ]
problem
nobody knew about any of this [ __ ] and
YouTube didn't communicate it to people
well let's do it
and of course a span of like one week we
went from making about $3 CPM to 25
season yeah and like I mean in your
defense we didn't show any of their
earnings just that's generally just
something we don't we've never done for
for whatever it's like old-school
etiquette yeah you don't share I mean it
causes so much drama yeah I mean there's
no question about it you know I'll cop
to it it was wrong to say that you know
to bring that into doubt in the first
place right it was [ __ ] I just I mean
I appreciate you know but again I it's
fairly defensible and in a way because
and that's part of what was so sinister
about what they were doing because you
can have someone like you here like I'm
actually having a really good amount
seems to be good and Casey was he just
thought we were all bitching yeah and
now just last month he's posting on
Twitter like a [ __ ] YouTube for not
monetizing my video and it's like man we
we've been getting killed out here for
for a minute yeah but I guess that
segues to my next point which is that
we're both critical people it's a part
of part of our profession what we do do
you have you ever gone hard on someone
or something and later with distance and
retrospect come to regret it or be like
yeah maybe maybe that was not the right
way to approach it
I mean honestly if I look back a lot of
my old stuff if I could go back and redo
a lot of my more negative videos in a
way that was less based around the kind
of firebrand almost entertainment
pundits
Kanna style doing things and just being
a bit more constructive in the
negativity I probably do that like I
think a lot of my old negative stuff was
like over exaggeration of you know oh
here's a really bad game look at how she
this is ha ha ha
like I could have used that time to look
at something that was better or at least
more interesting right and you can rag
on something and it's entertaining to
just rag on it but it's like well what
purpose did it serve no one was gonna
buy that shitty game in the first place
no one was gonna care and if we did
criticize something did we go too far to
try you know maybe to make people more
interested in watching our videos by
being hyperbolic yeah totally I think
like the thing I've been considering on
the last couple years is completely
killing the cynical drip run because I
don't think it actually represents what
we do anymore I don't think it has for a
while
it's it gives a you know it gives this
whole of angry video game nerd vibe
which were not you know he was always in
it for the comedy and that thing is like
a obviously a schtick right yeah it is
you know it's a persona yeah I don't
have a persona when it comes to
critiquing videogames right like there
may have been a bit of one back there
but these days now okay so I'd love to
take a hatchet to some of that old stuff
I really would and look at it and say
look it either this game is a waste of
time and we just ignore it cuz no one
was gonna even care about it people that
he cared about it cuz I told them to
look at how shitty it was you know you
feel bad for like the devs or you just
think that it's not a good way to I was
think it's a bad way to use an audience
as time I got wasted the audience no
yeah but it's not an entertainment
channel you know I mean if that's what
if that was the purpose did they get
more views those way totally yeah okay
cause they did but I look at it now and
like I really want to use that channel
as a platform at a time where there was
over six hours the good guys yeah oh
[ __ ] interesting is right there's 6,000
Steam games coming out this year at on
C's [ __ ] thousand right and there's a
bunch of stuff coming out that no one's
even looking at that's good it's like
really good it might not be perfect but
it's interesting and it's unique and it
deserves some support on a spotlight so
particularly over the last few years
with the diagnosis
being a not being able to work as much
let's come right really clear and a
focus that time is a very valuable
resource and not just my time the time
of the viewers so I should be making
something that is useful to them right
and you know poking you know kind of
doing the entertainment poking holes you
know if something that's obviously
shitty isn't it that you know that's not
useful that's a good point
that's a really powerful think yeah
that's cool I can see that from the way
that we make videos to like what we're
gonna just find something that's like
too obvious I don't know and just make a
video about it or really make an effort
to find something more interesting I
mean you're never gonna hit gold every
time yeah you know in my art my our goal
is to entertain people I know it's
different yeah but still we also have a
order which is what to talk about yeah
it's it's honestly come to the point
where we just don't make that many
videos anymore on h3 cuz I just I refuse
to force myself to react to something
that just isn't you don't either people
don't deserve to be made fun of or it
doesn't deserve to be [ __ ] on or it's
just not interesting it's like yeah
weirdly sometimes those videos yield
good results but it's like you have to
[ __ ] tear it out of you I want to ask
you this question and forgive them to go
girlfriend
the moment that I posted about this on
our subreddit every single question was
my raps gay I know I'll try I'll try to
take this in a direction you may not
expect I was like what the [ __ ] these
people are relentless oh yeah it was
like every single way and thanks to our
dutiful mods for who cleaned it up and
removed 99% of it part of the traps gay
but do you maybe well first you can you
explain what what I do yeah yeah yeah I
could totally do that so we run a little
convention in the UK every year called
Cox con it's started off as a joke like
Jesse Cox who's you know longtime friend
co-host of my podcast being around
forever
went to a show will call gay MOOC on in
the UK and he told his fans hey
to where we can do a panel gonna do a
meet and greet was great second year he
gets more involved with them and he
tells people to do it again well turns
out the show cancelled like right before
the event was supposed to start like
literally a day before they didn't have
the money so people were in the UK
that's spent money on hotels they spent
money on flights they gone often to do
Jessie felt personally responsible for
that because he's endorsed that show he
told people to come to see him so he's
like we're gonna I'm gonna make this
right and he took like 300 people till I
get arcade and did a bunch of cool stuff
on his old I on his own dime and he said
we're calling this Cox con now and that
joke became an actual show I was like
well I don't get over to UK very often I
really want an opportunity to connect
with our UK audience and give them a
place where they can meet us and
actually spend some real time with us on
a pretty small scale you know nothing
huge so we made a convention it's like I
think first year was a thousand tickets
and then we expanded it to one the half
thousand and that's where we kept it we
could go much bigger than that
but we didn't do it we sell out every
year so it has this very small community
feel we know a lot of the people that
come every year as a result of that so
third year in and we have a mixer vendor
stuff stuff for the expo floor panels
signing sessions all the kind of stuff
you usually expect at a convention and
Jesse opens the show everything's going
just fine there's like pretty much 1,200
people in the auditorium I think and he
does his little Q&A segment and some guy
stands up and he goes just kind of out
of nowhere
Jesse so our traps gay right jesse has
no idea what he's talking about
I saw the video he just looked confused
yeah he didn't look angry all right he
was just like no idea what this person
was talking about he's like what and
there's like a little bit of nervous
laughter around like we'd hop mic that
audience you watch some of the other
stuff the audience is loud like you'd be
able to tell if they were happy it was a
lot of like cringy kind of well kind of
laughter going on and he asks it again
and just sort of palms it off because
he's like he can see people
visibly uncomfortable mm-hmm and he just
like takes it off on a tangent and
that's that okay our staff notices we
have quite a few transgender guests that
come like they've been coming since year
one you know regular people they just
come to the convention down a couple of
days of no [ __ ] mm-hmm yeah to have
a nice friendly time with a group of
people that hopefully are all very
supportive and generally nice people
right yes that's your convention where
it's our convention that's what we
wanted to do that's why it's a small
private event it's like we're not
running PACs here we're not running RTX
you know we're not running twenty thirty
thousand people just one the half
thousand and the staff see there's a lot
of noticeably uncomfortable faces like
this girl who's really upset she's
crying sucks and the staff makes the
decision like what we're gonna do about
this like we don't know what you know
why this guy said this is here to troll
the event like is he here just to mess
it up for people is he here to actually
upset people or was you just like a
giant cringe Lord like yeah my
interpretation is that he probably
harmlessly was just trying to make a
joke that just didn't go over well right
yeah you see we thought that until and
this is obviously something we didn't
make public what we'd heard about one of
the staff had actually overheard this
guy at a bar like the night before cuz
there's a few bars around the hotels
that are near the conventions and the
ones literally in the convention center
when people are hanging around there
that I before and drink a lot and
apparently heard him talking to his
friends about his plan to sort of say
this and this had come up late I'm like
well you know we don't know for sure he
may have just said that while he was
drunk we don't know one way the other we
have some people who are uncomfortable
at the show then they don't feel
comfortable being here we need to do
something about it we need to do
something about it quick and we need to
do something about it in a way that
everybody knows so the best way we
thought to do that was well the staff
made the decision to get rid of them and
like well I could put it out on my
Twitter because I know everybody at this
show probably follows my Twitter it's
got the biggest reach out of all the
guests there yeah you know it's the best
way to do it without doing like we don't
do a PA announcement or anything yeah
we want to make sure we could find the
guy and you know revoke his past and
stuff without causing a scene without
causing any problems and that's what we
did I announced it I saw your tweet and
I guess a lot of people are saying that
you started a witch-hunt for this guy
nonsense I mean basically what we asked
for because we didn't we didn't have a
camera on the guy so we didn't know what
he looked like
yeah so what we did was we put out a
tweet saying hey does anybody know who
this person is because what we wanted to
do was to make sure the staff could go
find him yeah and explain to him what
why we were removing him and then
remember from the building right like we
never released his name because possibly
would never do that yeah I don't even
know what his name is I don't know it
looks like I had nothing to do with that
so I guess the crux of it as I
understand is that a lot of people
thought either you started a witch-hunt
or you overreacted to just a harmless
joke and you I guess a lot of people
were like oh you should have just
brushed it off and they've done yeah and
we could have done that but there were
also people in the audience that were
upset and ultimately sure the priority
is going to be the safety of the guests
it's got to be the guests being
comfortable and happy
we just wanted this small community
right convention where he felt safe so I
had I found this comment by someone who
I guess was offended by the way you
reacted to that okay and I thought like
it seems sincere so I thought it'd be
interesting to read this to you and get
your get your reaction to it because it
seems like some people who were your
fans for whatever reason were offended
so I thought maybe be interesting to to
try to like find a middle ground here
between you and these people who are
we're actually upset by this sir I'm
going to read this comment longtime fan
of total biscuits up until the meltdown
over the meme question at Cox con why
did he take the joke so seriously it
would have gone so much better for him
if he just laughed it off and then made
it seemingly unrelated comment about it
later assuming he felt that someone may
have seen it as transphobic Kohli a huge
amount of his fan base as well as casual
observers think that was poorly handled
at best so just to reiterate why gets so
up in arms over a joke and then he says
anyway no hostility meant and he what is
a fan of yours yeah well I mean I guess
I'd ask him the same question why I get
so up in arms over what we did right
ultimately it seems like none of the
people who were actually at the show
were upset about how we handled it right
like I know for a fact that people came
to me and said that they were not upset
quite the opposite that they were happy
that it that it had been handled that
way and it seems like when you know
there's a 4chan Brigade and you know
there's a bunch of subreddits that are
basically dedicated to trolling and you
know that they've gone after you on
purpose it's kind of hard to take
comments like that sincerely like what
would have been the best way to handle
it well not putting it out on my Twitter
would have probably been a better way to
handle it let's be completely honest
about that you know because even if that
had been handled in the most diplomatic
way possible which on the ground it was
you know it was the staff handling it
has all to do with me I'm not offended
by it
I'm not transgender yeah but there are
people who are and were and were upset
by it means from the outside I can I
mean I'm from the outside I agree with
you I don't understand why people would
get so Affairs something I missed cuz if
it's just that one nothing I know of
because that one tweet was not really
that hostile no it's it was interesting
because I I knew there was gonna be some
sort of alcalá sure I I could see that
coming a mile away
you know how the Internet is these days
yeah as that size was quite surprising
you know and how long the fact that this
is even still getting asked this how
many like you yeah like I don't think
about it but apparently some of these
guys still think about it even though
they weren't at the event and had no
intention of going to the event I mean
probably never would it's I'm just not
really sure why they're as unhappy as
they are you know I are they so
defensive over their meme I mean if
that's the case I've kind of got a roll
my eyes a little bit of that said you
know and there's a ball our meme isn't
offensive well to some people it is you
know you know I feel like I can absolve
oh yeah I don't understand the outrage I
mean you your intentions were work kind
your intentions were good and it seems
so minor it's a little strange it and
if I could go back in time do that thing
again yeah I'd remove the guy from the
show 100% would I put it out on Twitter
that we'd done it probably not we're
probably just have tried to reassure
people the show later that had come to
us and said they were upset about it
yeah you know our concern at the time
was this is the first time we've ever
had any kind of trouble at Cox con we
want to make sure that people feel like
this is a fun friendly place and they're
not gonna have any problems while I'm
here so if let's let's assume this guy
is a genuine caring big fan of yours who
was like man he didn't handle that well
like oh yeah
I'm upset with the way he handled that
like what would you say to him
I mean what I'd say to him is that the
way that I handle it was an attempt to
protect the volunteer staff that made
the decision that could not have handled
any of the [ __ ] that came their way had
they been the ones that were
front-facing on it like I didn't expect
as much as a shitstorm as there was and
there was a shitstorm it's strange but
I've dealt with that before and worse
right I can handle that some guy that
just signed on as a volunteer if they
got the both barrels of fortune they
could not and me being front facing on
it despite the fact that it was the
whole staff that made the decision was
as an effort to protect them mm-hmm
so could it have been handled better I
mean you can always say that in
hindsight right sure you know but
ultimately my priority is that the
people that went to the show know this
is going to be a friendly fun show and
they don't have to worry about that [ __ ]
they don't you know it's two days of
getting away from all the [ __ ] of
life on the air today you know you don't
want to bring it into the palace it's
our private show Ben ultimately we can
remove anyone for any reason there's no
free speech argument or anything despite
a lot of people try to make one you know
even if that was true it's in the UK we
don't have free speech of the UK so for
me being someone who's very critical - I
feel like with our fans like having that
critical perspective cuts both ways yeah
when they agree with you they love you
sure and then once they disagree with
you even a little bit it's like they
[ __ ] hate your guts
yeah and don't do it for a long time to
do spring set does that frustrate
totally yeah I mean like
when Trump won the election for instance
it was pretty now upset about it like
why because I've been listening to what
he'd been saying about health care and I
have stage four cancer my yeah that's a
pretty severe issue for me
yeah and I'm looking he's doing right
now like oh look he's doing exactly what
he said he would do like I'd listened to
what he said so the fact that he had got
elected that was like what the [ __ ] just
happened in the world right am I taking
crazy what's happening I've criticized
Trump in the past and it's frustrating
cuz it's like you've watched me for
years you like me and you like my
opinions and it's like this one time you
disagree with me you can't handle it
yeah that because it's like just it you
can it's okay to disagree with me here
and let's just move on yeah I mean it's
like oh I have to wonder if those people
are friends with anybody who doesn't
think exactly the same way they do they
do either politically or about anything
you know because if they are I have to
wonder how they manage it when they
react that way I think that people
buildup in their minds this image of
what they think this internet person
they watch on a daily basis is right
absolutely who they believe they are
they build them up higher and higher
they build them up bigger and stronger
than they ever could be and when
something when there's a crack in that
facade when finally they stay something
they don't agree with or they maybe make
a mistake as there ought to you know as
everyone is ought to do yeah sure of
course that's it like the whole giant
golden statue that they shatters into a
thousand pieces yeah and they'll never
forgive that person for that I don't
think in real life they have that
illusion about the people that they know
in real life like on the Internet where
it's like because our channel is I don't
I don't dangerous for a better word like
we a we we tend to appeal to both people
on the left and the right a lot of times
and so people who are conservative
leaning or left-leaning when I say
something that cuts against their
ideology because before that they're
always like oh he's one of us he's
definitely one of us that's the thing
and then they're like wait he's not one
of us yeah that's the thing it's all
fricken tribalism all of it yes it's
like you want someone as you've probably
heard this time and again you should
stop talking about politics like you
should stay in your lane that's right
right
the comedy yes it's a comedy yeah like a
registered voter every time like if I
follow Eric Andre and you'll say
something about Trump all the comments
are like stick to commenting to this
stick to that yeah that's people that
want you if you're not part of that team
they want you to shut up because they
actually have you used dangerous at that
point and I got a [ __ ] ton of I agree I
think a comment like that if anything is
is encouraging and and just shows how
brittle the opposing yeah it is that
they just crumble yeah under the
smallest criticism stick to comedy it's
like oh you're [ __ ] commenting on
Twitter where are your credentials
exactly inaudible do you have a degree
of any employee science degree you don't
need one
guess what you remoter just like
everybody else you know you and well
probably a lot of these people aren't
voting at all today yeah why don't you
stay in your lane you [ __ ] you even
twelve-year-old juice box drinking [ __ ]
indeed political opinions extend to how
good each brand of Capra's honest it
comes down to the fact that they want
you to shut up because they view you as
a threat mm-hmm that happens to anyone
that's in entertainment in particular
it's quite a shame I really I regret
because a lot of times I want to talk
openly about opinions I have but when it
comes to politics I really it's just not
worth it or get involved because you got
you you cut your audience
it really is every time I'll even met
you know I kind of keep a divide like I
keep politics out of my videos and I
keep it on Twitter I know if you don't
want it you don't have to follow me on
Twitter sure I keep it out of my
everything I started I started keeping
it yeah and you know at this point
everyone still divided it's like whose
[ __ ] mind am i changing you have
every late-night show host in the whole
[ __ ] country [ __ ] on Trump 24/7
what am I gonna add to that probably
nothing but simultaneously the risk is
that if you don't raise your voice the
people will end up speaking for you
might not be people you want speaking
for you yeah I totally agree with that
too
health care issues in particular yeah
you downright and passionate about it me
too my mom she recently had a her heart
failure she almost died she got a
pacemaker installed they ripped open her
chest it cost millions of dollars she
wouldn't they won't they if what he
wants to do passes she will not be able
to get insurance and I'm gonna be faced
with the choice of of letting my mom die
or bankrupt and myself and not ain't a
choice yeah that's the thing people need
to understand about health care is that
when a company has that power of life
and death in their hands that in a free
market anymore you don't have any power
as a consumer you got nothing they hold
all the cards which is why it's
important to look at government's
involvement health care and say you need
someone as big and scary as the
government backing you up because if you
don't have it no one else is gonna do it
you have no power in it obviously maybe
you could help me eliminate me because
I'm wondering like I know that like
generally I'm very left-leaning
especially on the on the issue of health
care right yeah like I I am a fan of
Obamacare it's helped my family a lot
personally and even me and HeLa before
we were making money yeah I know that
conservative people and people who are
against Obamacare are not bad people
they're good meaning they mean well and
they have good intentions as we all do
as human beings so I'm just trying to
get into their minds of what they they
think they're what is it that they're
think they're accomplishing by just
repealing what is existing and say why
is it so complicated the states everyone
else got to figure it out already I in
Israel I don't know you just have health
care it's not that complicated most
European countries so it's exactly the
same you know in the UK at least until
lately because the Conservative
government's there is [ __ ] with the
NHS really but you know but there's an
expectation that you grew up in the UK
you had health care
simple as that yeah like and they're
messing with it in a big way and that's
dangerous I don't know what the end game
is cuz you know you've got to assume at
some point that most people are good
well-meaning people don't assume that
yeah you might as well shoot yourself in
the head right now but it's true that's
true
just because it's like all these there's
I mean the country's got almost
completely vitae you got fifty percent
Democrats you got fifty percent
Republicans this is these people mean
well and they really I think in their
hearts and in their and their intentions
are trying to make the country better
but I just don't want their idea I don't
know they don't I guess there's a lot to
criticize Obama care I guess I'm even
when we had it it was super expensive
yeah and I don't know you still can't
see a doctor and seeing a doctor is so
expensive I mean there's but it's better
than not having that's exactly it
like it's a busted system and one its
Romney care like it was a Republican
plan that was compromised on time time
again just to even get it passed in the
first place it's not ideal so I'm close
to ideal but it's better than nothing
it's better than the medical bankruptcy
people were going through before that
it's better than being deny care
I've been denied insurance on the basis
of a pre-existing condition I'd be dead
no mom till there's no question I've got
dad I don't I don't have Obamacare
either I have private health insurance
but I couldn't have got it without the
pre-existing condition a vision
protecting me from being denied it yeah
right now so and my premium is going
twenty percent in January you know but
it's still better it's still better than
dying I think everything's dying like
you'll accept anything yeah anything
more than that but I wouldn't know what
that dumb plan is you're right I think
one I think it's just they're so
committed to their philosophy of
conservatism of government
non-intervention and free-market ideals
right that they think that the
government should never regulate
anything that health insurance should be
of a free market that dictates itself by
competition but it's like you says it's
it's when it comes down to an issues of
life and death there's no concerned
consumer choices a reasonable choice
exactly they can demand whatever they
want they're literally holding a gun to
your head and say pay me this much
enough to pull the trigger you don't
have any control which is why some stuff
you need the government for you know you
want to leave say the building of roads
to just random companies that just you
know
won't it's like oh well we all need
roads I let someone own the road
they could charge you whatever you want
for it on the show libertarian ideas of
all that kind of stuff there's some
stuff that has to be run by the
government I feel I make the road take
like a really long way so you have to
use their uber yeah they'll start
blowing up neighboring roads and [ __ ]
like oh god I dump truck just how I
think back in the day when the country
was smaller there was less people small
towns more competition because it wasn't
dominated by huge companies whose sole
purpose was to make as much money as
possible then free-market made a lot
more sense when you've got like three
mom-and-pop stores selling bread and
[ __ ] one you know it's like cool that
works but when you've got like five
insurance companies that are now
colluding together you know it's the
same with the internet I don't see how
people can't look at the way the
Internet monopolies work in this country
and not see that actually that's exactly
how other things would go were allowed
to go like that
that's how healthcare would go as well
yeah there's like way you have the
choice of oh you can have Time Warner or
[ __ ] you you know those you two choices
right so Comcast okay then the Nazi
Party reincarnated yeah I mean I believe
that's the technical term for them yeah
yeah it's a lot National Socialist Party
of Comcast yeah most people don't know
the real name you know back in back in
the old Articles of Incorporation right
but yeah it's I don't know I I think
it's American frontiersman attitude you
know and I'm sure they you you very much
recognize that that this American idea
of American individual independence back
from the days of the Wild West the days
full of the colonies like other
countries never really had that so they
never grew this idea of self-reliance
to an extreme sure and it's like well
every note for lions only goes so far
these days every I forget I think it was
Mark Twain who said it or maybe Kurt
Vonnegut every American is just a
temporarily embarrassed millionaire yeah
that was the good thing and that's why
they vote against their own interest
because like well someday that's gonna
screw me over cuz I'm super rich and I
don't want to be taxed etc so I'm gonna
vote in favor I don't look like when
Trump passes his tax reforms I'm gonna
be correct I'm gonna be wiping my tears
away with hundred-dollar bills
yes because it's like I lost the rest
call you know my taxes go down I don't
need my taxes to go down really I mean
I'm fine I'll happily what cause like
yeah he's gonna get screwed as a result
right yeah by the way that's the real
question
we're not billionaires either like we'll
make a couple hundred thousand extra
dollars a year but you've got [ __ ]
Apple and Google and Facebook who are
already offshoring billions of dollars
not paying taxes yes all the giant
[ __ ] Mac's but everything's
uncompromising you don't know anything
yeah yeah nobody know anyway everything
is so obscured information is like such
a commodity that I just don't I don't
know how to understand the amount of
information 1984 were like they keep
changing the history and you just keep
doubting everything so you just you just
don't even know no now we've always been
at war with Eurasia technique it's
definitely something in it you know
that's what its mass gaslighting in many
ways and there's the idea of crisis
fatigue I think they call it might have
so many [ __ ] problems bombarding you
all the time that you can't individually
care enough about order so then you end
up caring about none of them I think
sensitize me to all the [ __ ] that's
like living in Israel that's why
everyone's just upset and yelling you
can't even comprehend the amount of [ __ ]
that's wrong with your life yeah yeah
well okay well I know you had a huge
disagreement I don't know how huge it
was at a time but with yoke yoke cast
about disclosing sponsors oh yeah yeah
so my question not to get too into the
thick with that but do you think that
people disclosing sponsorships on
YouTube and on the Internet as general
has improved since that time I think get
us a bit
mostly by necessity and weirdly enough
the reason why it has is not through
channels wanting it to
it's because companies have been forcing
them to yeah I don't know if you've
noticed recently more more companies
have been like well we've always
disclosed because why share the same
opinion to you that it's important more
and more companies when we close deals
with them are like you have to put this
yep yep
I'm not never used to happen that in
fact the opposite used to happen they're
like oh yeah don't mention that you know
you don't need that's fine
now we just said here's a crazy example
for you just a few days ago Jesse Cox
had this playthrough of Uncharted right
he got a free copy of the game like
about three or four days after it came
out like Sony just sent him one sure I
kind of out of nowhere and it's like
okay sure so he does some videos for the
child thinks nothing although right a
couple of years down the line
Sony gets in touch women said yeah so
you're gonna need to add the following
disclosures thanks good idea because if
that was a free product so you need to
disclose that and it's like okay well I
can add it to the description the
child's like no no no if you have to go
back and edit the video I'm like no you
two doesn't work that way you can't do
that and they kept insisting no you have
to do it that's us covering he's just
deleted the whole thing now because yeah
and it really is serious
ask her it's insane like you [ __ ] up
that's not even a sponsorship that's
like just sending a free copy of a game
to someone has a YouTube channel is
commonplace business there's nothing
unusual about that but yeah I think it
is changing for the better but mostly
because companies got uber paranoid
about it because the FTC has become
aware of what's going on yeah so they've
got crazy paranoid about it there's
still a lot of youtubers I don't want to
name names because I don't think it's
worth getting into but I see a lot of
people and to like the discerning eye
it's so obvious yes that it's sponsored
and they do action anywhere and it's
like dude like just [ __ ] today yeah
it is because they know they have a
younger audience that would be
disillusioned by the cloud
yeah we come right down the whole idea
of the golden God you know and these
guys are encouraging that behavior
they're like they relish the fact they
have a bunch of teenage friends that
look up to them as [ __ ] demigods and
they could they could never be impugned
by something like a sponsorship I do it
for the fans and I wanna do for the view
I'm gonna take a ride in a mercedes-benz
but it's for you it's for you the viewer
it's like I buy these thousand dollar
shirts for you cynical pieces I remember
the first time we had our sponsored
content it was really I was super
nervous about you know doing a sponsored
spot and disclosing it and saying and
ours are obvious we don't have likes
tricky ones it's like thanks to audible
of course yeah that's the best kind I
agree when you've got something that's
not even really connected to your
products they that's that's awesome like
sponsorships we take like those are the
best they're fantastic generally the
only ones that work with yeah and it
doesn't cost poems with the audience
generally speaking there are people that
it did you know that they're just gonna
have to deal with that you know sorry
I'm sorry I'm trying to make money
nobody so the most part everyone was
super respectful I mean but a lot of
people were happy there like a good for
you dude maybe I'm already with them so
it's great to see that you know two of
my interests account if in the same
space now that's cool
I think it's an increasingly more
important to that people understand the
necessity of of that yeah I think the
more people understand the business
maybe we can tone down some of the like
really nasty rhetoric that goes on with
it so if they know the reality of
running a YouTube channel is business if
they know the reality of how sponsorship
works and how disclosure should work
then people get less upset when
something like that happens sure so I
you know I believe in pure transparency
when it comes to that stuff I have the
longest time I over disclose it's become
a joke
yeah industry's like oh it's closed and
small but he's probably got 20
disclosure messages in the first five
minutes yeah and I was like yeah
probably I'll just put it every much
plastering over absolutely everything
that's definitely one of my pet peeves
I'd say these days when I see people not
disclosing yeah it's gonna bring the
hammer down
necessarily like just like going to a
key it's a key it's just a key and
there's people that I respect that do it
and I'm like yeah why are you [ __ ]
doing this it's not necessary brought up
the Yogscast there's the you see right
there those were guys that were my
friends you know several on the came to
my wedding for God's sake right and when
I see them pulling [ __ ] like that
knowing how
successful they were back then like why
are you doing that man you know no go a
young audience don't mislead them I know
and they'll be fine
they'll be fine if you disclose it
you're not gonna lose all your audience
yeah it's what's weird that people are
so scared of that but it really goes
back to the csgo a lot of them which was
like kind of the rock bottom
oh yeah of that were you surprised by
that like scandal were you aware of it
before it broke or wasn't because I
wasn't really big into csgo seemed like
I knew you could bet skins cuz I've done
it like in DotA once like and lost a
bunch of rares or something I think I
found international three or four
something and like I didn't realise how
big an industry it was but then Singh
I'd seen this gambling sponsorships
going around like big streamers taking
these there on all these videos I'm like
that seems a bit shitty but if they're
just disclosed sponsorships which they
were at the time that's fine and then of
course you find out that they only oh by
the way for anyone who doesn't know
about this it was a huge scandal yep
these namely around two youtubers and
counter-strike personalities tmartn its
and the Bass Pro syndicate that's not
only Jojo jihad yes slippin I don't know
how I remember looking at the artists of
Incorporation and I guess for some
reason his name didn't ring out to me
when I was that yeah was there but
there's these prominent guys and they
were promoting and promoting this
gambling site and never disclosing that
they actually owned it which came with a
whole slew of complications one being
that they can control the outcome the
[ __ ] bets so that that was that was
incredible and now what's even more
incredible is that it doesn't seem to
have gone away I'm seeing csgo gambling
sites back on the rise yeah they've
they've kind of changed things around
they're made of unofficial loot boxes I
think they call them now where's like oh
you can open a custom crate I think is
the name of it it's the same [ __ ] it's
just packaged in a different way and
there was a report I think Richard Lewis
wrote it he did an investigative stuff
on this and there's something they
literally called The Rape algorithm yeah
classy [ __ ] right and this is something
that they could turn on
at will when they knew that there was
someone who was spending a bunch on the
site and it would turn the order down
yeah yeah right then I work full control
over it I worked in gambling when I was
in Israel and we see the same thing when
we had high-risk players this was a
actual gambling site one of the major
ones they would they would have what was
called risk management and if they had a
player who was either winning or betting
a ton of money they would they would
manually put a warning on him and the
platform this is a platform that served
hundreds of sites have powered hundreds
of sites and it would just guarantee
that he lost yeah probably the same
algorithm is in like a [ __ ] ton of
different csgo betting sites probably
all of them as far as we know we know
that report was based in experience I
can almost guarantee it
yeah well the same guy that made it and
then sold it to all these other sites is
there anything going on today that
bothers you like the disclosure issue or
the old days I don't know I mean I think
it's it's still not as great as it could
be like we've gone through so much and
then we're still having issues with
disclosure that just makes me roll my
eyes like how can we still be having
that as a problem and now we're seeing
that it's it's you know the [ __ ] has
had an effect you know the ad pocalypse
is the result of a lot of things some of
which are outside of our control and
some of which were you know and
regardless of whether or not the
reputation was earned regardless of who
directly was responsible or not
responsible for it YouTube suddenly got
a reputation of being an unsafe place to
put your ads right and there's a lot of
contributing factors to that that's
built up over the years and you look at
all of these scandals they're part of
that you look at all the [ __ ] all
the shitty videos all the dishonesty all
the people that think hey you know
running around screaming rape rape rape
over and over again to an audience of
eight-year-olds as an acceptable form of
entertainment that's fair I mean all of
that is a factor and it's all and it
came to a head eventually it would and
it was inevitable yeah it was inevitable
in 2000 2016 2017 is when it happened we
all got [ __ ] the thing that was
shocking was
it was so much worse that I actually
even thought because I always figured in
my mind something like that would
probably happen eventually but it was so
much worse than I thought you like how
much nice yeah yeah but I mean it was
all to me for the best but I think
that's a fair point I mean we flew too
close to the Sun here on YouTube the
rules first for so long yeah I mean you
still have to is still like blame the
appetizer to some extent there cuz like
as you've said time and again and you're
right
people advertise and sponsor some really
offensive [ __ ] and it's fine why because
they know what their target market is
they know what the target demographic is
that's all advertising is about getting
the right product to the right person
that's when it's worth money otherwise
it's worthless don't wanna sell skin
care lotion to a 65 year old man he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
you want to be selling him blankets and
bourbon I guess right yeah the thing is
that they could do a hell of a better
job when it comes to targeting the
rabbit and understanding what these
videos aren't who they're for getting it
they're very far behind on that and
we're seeing some companies they do get
it like audible you know great example
yeah that's the kind of company that
they got on board with podcasts cuz they
realized this was how a lot of young
professionals are consuming
entertainment these days right perfect
match made in heaven in terms of
advertising yeah more companies need to
be doing that the podcasting sphere has
really marketable yeah I think just
because it's generally professional to a
degree yeah you know exactly what you're
getting and and but it's interesting in
a way I feel like you know we can talk
about anything
it's like took more traditional media
because they are sponsoring our show and
us and they know us I understand the
format isn't predictable so there's no
surprises yeah they know they're you're
known quantity to them and they knew
what they signed up for but with
youtubers there's so much content coming
out every day that people don't really
know what they signed up for do they
that's how it was
yeah and I think YouTube have to accept
the blame for not tightening that ship
sooner before we all got [ __ ] killed
yes
Isis yeah only allowing those ads to run
in the first place you probably have all
this machine learning you have all these
BOTS now so you'll and go through are
you kidding
the biggest ad provider in the world
couldn't handle that [ __ ] right it's
unbelievable I agree and on the other
hand you and like you said you blame the
advertisers I mean I made this video
recently these same brands that were
boycotting YouTube have ads on CNN
during a live shooting exactly it's like
where's your [ __ ] moral compass
yeah suddenly disappears when it's like
oh there's a lot of views on that so
let's get a little bit disaster porn
yeah going on which is let's be honest
what that is I think we all [ __ ] up to
be honest it was just it was a perfect
storm yes I know yeah and everyone we
all ended up burning everyone kept see
well let's just say I'm drinking coke I
guess the one final art walk one other
thing was uh I guess you probably saw a
video game donkeys video about his he
had a fiery criticism of game Journal
but he did yeah well how did you feel
about that video I guess and just to set
it up a little bit for the audience
he basically his main criticism against
them was that their rating system was
just complete [ __ ] you you you'll
say the game was awful I hated playing
it and then you go to mini critic and
it's got like a 75 and it's like what
what is even the point anymore and that
was one of my one of my big takeaways
look what do you think about his videos
all my big takeaways as well I've been
against schools since at the very outset
I've never given a score in my life and
I never will because frankly you're
trying to take a piece of unique art and
boil it down to a number which goes into
a bag with a bunch of other numbers that
have decided on a completely different
way I'll tell you a problem you respect
it too much well yeah I mean that's not
a prime in yeah I'm telling you wrong
and your response you respect it as an
art form where these guys are it's a
it's an industry yeah that pumping it
out says hey you know the reason why
they will not stop giving scores like
well too many people want them like yeah
well what about what happened to being
the change you want to say
you know if you're gonna write a review
did you take pride in that review yeah
you obviously didn't because you wanted
to boil it down to an arbitrary number
that means nothing at the end of you
rather than having people read the
[ __ ] review that's insane to me that
you would ever want that right and then
one of the other takeaways that it was
like whatever happened to bad [ __ ]
it's like we all understand that a
seventy all the sudden is like decades
don't ever pay ya what whatever happened
to a badge triple again because they
certainly exist don't exist in
apparently not you know they disappeared
in the ether like dunkey in many ways
was completely on point and a lot of the
very defensive responses that came from
a lot of the old media in regards to his
video showed that they knew they know
what's going on they're just protecting
their business they're protecting their
own that's all they do their circle the
wagons every time it's with the you know
remember the cuphead video where that
guy couldn't get past the tutorial like
the hungry sling a bunch of people after
them and then you get these bunch of
articles week down the wire but gamer
toxicity and I think there was one I'd
laughed my ass off at this gamers need
to stop fetishizing skill oh my god why
isn't it cool to watch someone do a cool
thing really well sizing skill yeah stop
fetishizing homeruns and score you know
and team's winning I just want to see
[ __ ] dudes slapping each other's
asses that's what I got it for yep game
critics graham critics can't take
criticism I get that every day as a
criticism of me and I don't blame people
but I mean there's I think there might
be a game of a kernel of truth to
critics generally have a hard time
taking criticism
I find that about myself sometimes where
I'm like my first reaction is can tend
to be defensive yes and then I'll be
like dude don't be [ __ ] don't be so
[ __ ] full yourself dude just like
chill out and I feel like I've gotten
worse - yeah back in the day I think I
was way more receptive and way more
down-to-earth and it just happens
without me knowing because I feel like
I'm the same person but sometimes I'll
get defensive
and then I'll realize like oh my god I'm
[ __ ] like worse here's why you feel
this way right because you've got a
proven product you've got a show it's
really popular there are a lot of people
like you've made a business out of it
you've got a studio you clearly see the
objective results of your success and
that success came from you doing things
the right way like that is proof
positive that what you are doing is the
right thing so when someone comes along
and says what you're doing is the wrong
thing your immediate reaction is like
cognitive dissonance like you can see
clearly in front of you that what you've
done is the right thing but there's a
part of you saying I should listen to
criticism from this guy but he's saying
I'm doing the wrong thing but how can I
be doing the wrong thing if all of this
you know if 3 million views here 5
million views here successful podcast
here successful t-shirt line here and I
think as a critic in particular you
spend your days thinking of ways to give
better criticism and to do it in a way
that is informative to do in a way that
can look at multiple points of view and
try and step out of your own shoes and
maybe look through a different
perspective a different lens and you try
and do in a way that's not just designed
to upset somebody and then a lot of
these guys come along and they don't
know how to do that because criticism is
a skill something you could learn how to
do critical thinking is a skill
something you have to learn how to do
and a lot of these guys are actually
really bad at criticism they come along
and you know if I come along and call
you a piece of [ __ ] is that a good
critique of your videos yeah it's not a
father could think of anything so even
valid critique of you you will that
alone because I didn't even justify what
I just said why yeah that's that that's
why why am i a piece of [ __ ]
I'd like can they even come up with an
answer for it more than not you ask him
that question they have no answer or
their answers [ __ ] it's like well
eight years ago you said this I'm like
did I where's the evidence of that and
then they go silent like they have this
idea and their mind they just want to
lash out at you and they just want to
say their piece and that's more from not
what it is never got this you know a few
years ago I turn the pot the comments
off of my videos right wow I actually
didn't know that took the plunge I took
the risk because there's a financial hit
to do in that YouTube does not like you
doing that really yep yeah you mean in
less views yeah Plus view so it hits the
SEO basically because it's you turning
off a form of engagement
so you know how you can get hit by that
you know this the reason why if people
don't know that you asked for likes and
favorites and subscriptions because
those are their engagement data points
but YouTube likes to reward you one so
essentially you're just like I don't it
was from a point of just not wanting to
see the comments yeah it was mostly that
like just you know I have a bad
relationship with Internet comments you
know and that's a lot of that's on me
but it got to the point especially when
I was diagnosed I'm like I don't need
the stress in my life so yeah I like to
make a joke that YouTube comments gave
me cancer I think they actually it is
possible but you know what's really
interesting about that is I turned the
comments off and yet we've got to set up
in a way where you can leave a comment
but no one will ever see it right so
it's on approval only when we never look
at the list okay there's still several
hundred comments every single video well
despite what that says and that's that's
the interesting thing I think people
sometimes they just want to say their
piece and get it out there right they
don't even care if anybody reads it so
we gotta leave it like that and the
shout into the void and I wonder if that
made them feel better
probably they probably a part that's
part of the reason why internet comments
are so awful for people like us who are
on the receiving end of them because
they never assumed that you're there
you're actually reading them yeah or
that you're even a real person yeah
they've maybe just had a really bad day
he decided to take it out on somebody
and then moved on with them and for you
that's a pile of the hundred negative
horrible things you've got said about
you today and that you go to sleep
thinking about yeah so yeah it doesn't
make it yeah never turn them back on I
think like we have a place where people
can talk anywhere we have a subreddit
yeah so we're like if people if you
really want to talk they can take the
extra step to do that like I think your
comments actually too easy that's the
problem that's why people leave so many
[ __ ] ones we got a question from
weekdays here these days are you there
buddy
yeah how are you doing hello hello
weekdays he's in the week my friend
feels happy and alone oh there you are
there we go sorry
hey what up Dave
how are you yeah my question well you
guys kind of touched on it earlier it
was about kind of how gaming and
journalism has changed throughout the
years I wanted to ask tibi if he thinks
it's gone in a positive or negative
direction overall good question
I think thank you obviously see in the
week I think honestly it's got better
because it's there are more ways now
that a consumer can get the information
think about how it used to be when we
were growing up where do we get our info
we didn't get it for the internet we
didn't have it we had to buy a gaming
magazine guess what half the gaming
magazines were owned by the people who
were making the games beta Nintendo
Power was there ever a bad review of the
Nintendo programs and the park also was
there like man this Mario sir oh yeah
it's like totally crap yeah it's also
high you know guy who's working the cue
ball next to me he was literally the
Nintendo office yeah it's got so much
better because we have so many different
ways to do it and if you'd come if you
find someone that you're not a fan of
you can go and find somebody else we're
like almost spoiled for choice and you
can experience in different ways if you
want to read a three-minute the all
review you want to even just read a
score or watch a little video you can do
it anyone with a 45 minute video you can
do it you want to watch a 12 hour stream
you can do it right so you have so many
different ways and all of those things
you can call them games journalism or
not but the only thing that is really
important to me is that these things
communicate accurate information to the
consumer so they can make a decision
about where that hard-earned $60 ghost
sure and we have more ways than ever to
do that so even though there's a bunch
of [ __ ] going on and games journalism
science has no idea what to do with
itself or writes a bunch of stupid
articles about fetishizing skill and god
knows what else and how which has too
many white people it's ultimately a
place where we just have a lot more
choice than we did that's yeah that's
good I mean definitely so the last thing
I want to touch on is obviously you've
had a very public battle with cancer
yeah yeah it's been going on for how
long I mean how long have you been
living with cancer now I'm over three
years I think honestly the you've
handled it with like great grace and
optimism from from the very beginning
that's inspired
me and first of all thank you for for
doing that okay and I think it's been a
beacon of light I think for a lot of
people of just like seeing how you can
handle it with with dignity and I know
that heelas dealing with some her dad
just got recently diagnosed with cancer
we were talking about it backstage and
it's really nice to hear you being you
know optimistic about it basically well
firt my first question is because the
last update that I was able to find was
from like June or some show yeah how's
it going
whatever worried about this so basically
where we are right now is that it is
stabilized meaning it's not gone away
but it's not growing so there's a couple
of small tumors in my liver and there's
one very very small nodule in my lung
so it's Stage four which means it spread
past the initial place it was Stage four
is pretty bad
that's when survival chances go in the
toilet on October the 15th 2000 17 2015
sorry I was told you've probably got two
years to live that was two years and
five days ago but cancer did so [ __ ]
those odds and [ __ ] yeah but the problem
with Matt metabolized cancer is the
metastasized cancer sorry is thick it
can go anywhere it gets in the blood it
can spread to any organ becomes hard at
nail it down you know you can't do
targeted therapies as easily you can't
just cut it out so it being stable at
this stage is very very good because it
means the therapy works and it is
continuing to work and I have fairly
minimal side effects still got my beard
still got me through my shirt I mean you
know you don't look like a guy who has
cancer yeah I sure as hell did you know
there was a people were asking I don't
if you know I did a voice back for
Starcraft 2 and the photo they gave for
me for that was in black and white
people like did he die is that why they
know who I looked terrible of that photo
but it you know I the chemo sucks
of course it sucks I have every two
weeks I got plugged in on the Wednesday
I get the big dose in the
the clinic and then there popped me on a
portable thing to take home for the rest
of it until Friday so I'm pretty much
like out of action for two days and then
I test about two days to really get back
on my feet you know what is that
experience like I feel like this
conversation doesn't exist anyway you go
through this every two weeks and you're
managing to keep everything going
yes I mean I don't see another option
you know it's like everyone has a job
you know it's you know my job so huge
motivator for me you know I'm proud of
what I do and I enjoy it and I know that
I'm very blessed to be able to do it as
a career so I want to take every
opportunity I can to do it that's why
I'm out here I'm at twitchcon that's why
I'm going to blows cards you know I want
to take joy in that and I get a lot of
satisfaction out of it and that also
means I want to be back on my feet as
quick as possible so you know I look at
it and I say right okay I've got ten if
I if I can get back on my feet got ten
good days and four bad days every two
weeks and you know what that's okay
I got rather have 14 good days but I
can't have 14 good day so I'll take 10
that's okay and I mean the experience of
actually being on the therapy itself I
mean essentially turns into a zombie
it's one of the best ways to describe it
I mean it's your whole body is in pain I
just constant aching there's a feeling
of sickness although that varies on a
person-to-person basis I get a subdermal
injection right here it's quite new they
only just started doing this and it's a
gel and it slowly goes into your
bloodstream of course about five days
and it's an antiemetic so it's an
anti-nausea gel it knocked the nausea on
the head in a really good way like you
still feel a bit sick but I used to like
throw up like eight times ten times a
day like until I was just throwing up
stomach acid that's gonna be just burned
it was nothing but burning that part of
chemo has got to be really difficult to
the healing process right yeah think of
knocking yeah because you get massively
dehydrated like that's the advice that I
give to anyone I was to go through
chemotherapy two things one hydrate for
the love of God like drink fruit juice
in particular don't drink water drink
fruit juice it gives us yep calories
sugar really important the taste will
help you drink
faster in my case one of my side effects
is I have a cold sensitivity while I'm
on the pump so if I drink something too
cold it can shut my throat and kill me
oh my god yeah also if I just touch
something that's too cold nice that kind
of sucks so I've gotta wear gloves and
make sure you know stuffs at room
temperature before I drink it but I
found the like drinking fruit juice I
can drink it a lot faster that means I
can hydrate better and the other thing
is force yourself to eat you threw it up
[ __ ] you eat it again just not the same
thing obviously don't care yeah just
keep eating
dude like because it is fuel it
literally is fuel it's fuel to fight if
you give up on that everything gives up
but every time I eat even if I don't
like the taste of it I don't like the
feeling of eating it about ten minutes
after I've eaten or even as I'm eating
I'll feel this burst of energy like it's
like becoming awake again at least for a
couple of hours
it's incredible to hear that because I
feel yeah all of us who aren't sick we
take food for such granted right and
also it's the most basic thing that you
can think of you gotta feel yourself to
continue right it's so obvious until
your body is screaming at you not to
mm-hmm
and telling you I'm gonna throw that up
if you do that I'm just like no you're
not I'm gonna eat it and if I throw it
up I'm gonna cook another thing and I'm
gonna eat that
until something stays down because you
need those nutrition you need you need
that nutrition if you don't have it your
cover is gonna get longer or longer and
your your immune systems gonna just
collapse you know I have a surprisingly
strong immune system I should have no
immune system by now my immune system is
fine it's taking a bit of a beating but
it's fine
a lot of people in my stage can't even
travel because it'll kill him you know
catch a cold he dead for me now I've
been fortunate in that they found the
right combination of drugs they found a
chemo that was unpleasant but I could
tolerate it and I've got a good
oncologist that knows what he's doing so
you know all I need him to do is keep
giving me the stuff that works and I'll
keep fighting it and I'll keep going and
that's the only option there is just to
keep going but what other option is
there you just give up nah there's
nothing else nothing beyond this mm-hmm
you've got to fight ten good days for
bad days even if it's one good day
thirteen bad days that's still one good
day do you find that you've become more
optimistic in some way since your
diagnosis will in some ways like it's
hard to worry about petty [ __ ] when
you've got you know death staring you in
the face do you feel like you have some
knowledge that you wish you could share
like I know for example to use it mildly
you'll get a flu and you'll be like man
I can't [ __ ] wait till I'm not sick
again and then the moment you're better
you forget all about that is there some
kind of feeling that you're always
having like that that you wish you could
just [ __ ] that you wish everyone could
appreciate and feel is that something a
minute think of chemo was getting over
the worst flu of your life and feeling
like you were not a real person while
you had it that sounds off like you know
you were zombie I even trapped in your
own head sometimes I think about being
so tired that you can't watch Netflix
it's too exhausting that that's what it
does to you and as a result well you got
to do you get trapped in your own mind
I even listening to things like
audiobooks it's like bright light sounds
anything any kind of stimulus becomes
scary it's you know you jump in at
shadows it it screws with your mind it
screws with your head in a big way
there's a fog paranoia it is a really
nasty thing to put in your body but
ultimately you got to do it and you got
to keep doing it if you want to actually
overcome it there's no easy way to do
chemotherapy there's no magical advice
but there is stuff you have to do it's
tough it helps to have someone close by
you helps to have someone like my wife
that will push me to do these things
that will say you've gotta wait you've
got a drink I don't care what you think
eat the [ __ ] food having somebody
like that having that kind of support
system is essential I don't think I'd be
alive if I didn't have that god bless
her dude well that's really inspiring it
it is what it is you play the handi delt
you do the best you can you don't give
up on it you know it's because it's not
just giving up on your life
it's giving up on everyone that's ever
being touched by what you've done your
friends your family pets for God's sake
you know you want to be there for them
like they deserve to have you there for
them mmm the only way that that's going
to happen is if you keep fighting and
it's possible like [ __ ] these statistics
they don't mean anything if you don't
like the statistics change the stats now
live long outlive it just keep going
because science is [ __ ] amazing and
they come up with new stuff every day
they come up with new treatments all the
time do you think that chemo will be
looked back on and hopefully as soon as
ten years as this like almost like how
we used to electrocute people with
illnesses well we look like as leeches
only Bob yes because we're killing the
patient and hoping the cancer dies
faster right it's not a great way to do
things but it's the best thing we've got
right now there's a general first line
of defense is not the only thing and
people should be aware of that you know
if chemo fails for us I have a neighbor
she's had stage 4 cancer for 20 years
that's he's currently doing
immunotherapy brand-new immunotherapy
she's doing really well on it like the
tumors are shrinking she had cancer all
over her body you'd be shocked by what
is out there or what is being developed
right as we speak that's awesome and all
you got to do as someone that has it is
to give those guys a bit more time give
them as much time as you can give them
and that means putting in your F and
surviving alright right simple as that
really
is there a organisation that we can
donate to that you in particular
hi holding high interest that's worthy
of people's money I mean there's quite a
few I what you got to watch out for with
cancer in particular there's a few that
are not a good idea like I always get
upset in October because it's Breast
Cancer Awareness Month and a lot of the
companies donate to Susan Susan G Komen
right which is a terrible organization
they they waste money on awareness
raising they waste money all over the
place they don't miss research and they
sue other charities there are disgusting
organized
fighting in the Hall of cancer
absolutely horrendous
so what are we send my yeah you can send
rate money to a local Research Hospital
you'd be surprised and helpful I can be
you can donate directly to your local
research hospital look up la like I
would if it's me just LA cancer a bum
here's me yelling that will be a there
will be a link to donate to them like I
always won going directly towards the
fight you've got these huge
organizations like American cancer
cancer society Society or whatever and
I'm like if I give them five thousand
bucks what was it go where's that money
going yeah it's always good to look on
Charity Navigator yeah that's a very
good site for figuring out where the
money is going and look at the breakdown
look at how much is going to research
versus administrative cost versus
awareness should be on a research spread
awareness for some counselors it's quite
know about cancer yeah people they do I
don't know where yeah there's still some
things that would be good I would like
to see there be a bigger push to get
there for younger men especially when
they have symptoms to go and get checked
that's what I said when I first got
diagnosed I you know I had colon cancer
it's embarrassing you don't want to do
it at this age nobody thinks they've got
talking about stage it's like in America
they don't even recommend you get a
finger up the ass until you're like
50/50 now that wonderful experience of
like twenty eight or whatever but
ultimately yeah it's [ __ ]
embarrassing you know it's more
embarrassing dying that's pretty shitty
yeah
[ __ ] yourself when you die maybe
some mm it's yeah but ultimately people
have to take their own health seriously
and if they see symptoms for the love of
God please please if it's nothing
[ __ ] celebrate the fact that it's
nothing
sure okay you just went through some
unpleasant [ __ ] you maybe you got a
colonoscopy roll a finger up your eyes
big [ __ ] deal you're gonna have to
have it sooner or later
yeah it's gonna have to happen so you
might as well get it after death yeah
pick one
I get fingered all day boy hmm I think
it's pretty obvious choice yeah I think
that's actually really important and to
where he's that awareness yeah I mean
take your own I'll just go to the
[ __ ] doctor I'm I think we're all
guilty or prolonging we absolutely are
you know it's like but man you got to
take care of your chef you do ultimately
I could have
way better position if I had and I
didn't cuz I was embarrassed
right yeah how long did you have
symptoms but didn't go to the dot out of
you really a year yeah it's like cuz
there's a bunch of other explanations
for and you always assume oh it's
something else it's my dime may I ask
what symptoms are is that too personal
that's all people about it you're in my
initial video you know it's we're
talking about [ __ ] like you know weird
cold stool rectal bleeding you know the
kind of thing is like you see blood
knees still like oh maybe I just had a
you know a raw steak you know rest ache
or whatever off you rationalize it away
oh yeah I mean I thought I had IBS I
thought I had maybe even Crohn's you
know what something like that yeah or
diverticulitis I didn't think I had
colon cancer you know you always assume
it's not cancer it's something else be
fine
yeah and then you yeah you prolong any
like you know what this is uncomfortable
as defined then you eventually like
alright I'm gonna go find out if I have
Crohn's or what I was like now you have
colon cancer like well that's [ __ ] yeah
I probably should have gone earlier you
know and anybody if you out the symptom
like that don't [ __ ] ignore it don't
ya it's embarrassing get over it go to a
doctor for a love God you know save
yourself a [ __ ] ton of pain later on
right is there something about cancer
that like you came to learn by being
through it that most people don't know
it there's no feeling of having it like
right now if you asked like do you feel
like you have an illness no I mean
that's what's really talking to my dad
like you can't confront the fact that is
so yield because it doesn't feel it has
a really bad coughing about when it
doesn't it feels it feels not completely
normal yeah I don't know a vacuum I
don't feel that I have a tumor in my
liver or in my lung that's that doesn't
impact my daily life you know there's
probably some pain there but you know
I'm on painkillers it's probably just
buried there somewhere and the weird
thing is I guess you know people view
cancer as this thing which will be no
turning into a desiccated husk
immediately when you've got it and
completely destroy your life no it
really doesn't and that's actually
scarier
mmm cuz you know you've got a cut on
your arm and it's bleeding you can see
I've been wounded and you have a
response to that
you got something inside you that might
be silently eating away at you you don't
you don't even feel it's there and it's
good on that pain response no it's
disturbing it's it's insidious and
obviously a lot of it comes down the
fact you don't feel it before either
you don't feel it before the diagnosis
but you still don't feel afterwards
either you only feel everything around
it you know the side effects of the
chemo the pain from say you know the
fact that I've had an abdominal hernia
for years from the surgery you know
collapse muscle wall things like that
you know
yeah you have to take painkillers to
just manage that and stay functional
mm-hmm but the actual disease no it's
just there it's invisible mmm that's
creepy as [ __ ] that is [ __ ] weird do
you ever feel like irrationally angry at
your own body for trying to kill you
totally it's like [ __ ] off yeah I think
that's quite healthy
like being able to visualize it as a
thing you can fight it's much better
than having it be a thing you don't
understand right and a lot of people do
that that's like it's recommended even
you have an enemy they identify you have
an enemy you can see you could imagine
what it looks like you can imagine what
you have to do to defeat it versus
something you don't understand spreading
throughout your body without any what
you know without you even noticing and
with there being no solid easy take this
pill and you'll get better option sure
that's that's that's scary I don't think
about it that way though you know I was
viewed as the enemy ever since I got it
I view it as something beatable because
it is you know and every time we get a
scan and we see it's either shrunken or
begum like we're winning it seems like
you've been fighting it successfully for
a long time you've beat the odds and it
seems that every time there's update its
it's good news or at least not bad news
yeah exactly you know see at least not
bad news is good you know you know you
love that miraculous remission where
it's juicy you coming it's gone but I'm
faces all the reality that that's
probably not going to happen
you just got to kind of live with it you
know I know I'm gonna need this
treatment indefinitely do you think that
that kind of uh personifying it as the
enemy is has been one of the keys to
your fighting it successfully
I think so mentally and physically and
mentally such so important it it sounds
like a cliche it's not I know it is 90%
mental because that's what drives
everything else
it drives your ability to fight it
physically it drives your ability to
rehydrate and to want to get better and
to make sure you eat and fuel your body
and all that sort of thing to get up and
not skip that treatment this way it's
like I could not go in because I know
it's gonna hurt to be fine but I'll go
in line yeah exactly scared that's the
scary thing you'll feel I'll skip it and
off you're fine yeah and what if I just
skip the next one as well like that's
[ __ ] up mm-hmm
but you but you get up you know get up
at 9:00 a.m. on that Wednesday I go in
they do the blood test I know I'm there
get a needle and they plug it in right
there I can see you know plug it into
the port goes in there stays in there
for two days they rip it out
it tastes saline as they flush it you
know to make sure that it's clean and
then you do all over again and you've
got to just keep doing it because if you
tap out on that that's it because this
ain't gonna give up this is gonna keep
trying to kill you so you have to keep
fighting it back you can't just give it
a break is there something I noticed you
saying something about like you do you
appreciate time in a different way
because I something you said this truck
with me is like I get ten good days and
four bad days and that's enough for me
do you have a different appreciation for
time yeah it was like him you know when
we were talking earlier about what I go
back and you know redo a video or change
the way that I criticize things I think
a lot of that came from that directly
it's like I can do a limited number of
videos less than I used to be able to do
I can work less than I used to be able
to do I can play less than I used to be
able to do so let's make sure that time
counts for something a lot of it is also
you assume at this age you've
well I've got fifty sixty years the
family what if you didn't well you know
you don't know how long you've got so
you know made me want to try and be a
better dad there's no doubt about that
you know I wanted to connect more with
my stepson then I have and I've been
doing that I wanted to connect more with
my wife make sure that we get a good you
know we get a good run out of it I
intend to be around when I'm [ __ ] 100
years old we'll be still bitching about
video games if I can be but sometimes
there might be something outside of my
control
you know maybe fighting isn't enough
maybe that's just not enough to keep
going but if that's the case then you've
got to make sure that you spend the time
you've got in the best way you can and
even then it's not like it changes you
overnight like you still want to go
reread it comments you still want to go
it's your people on Twitter like you
can't change the habit of a lifetime but
there's something of the back of your
mind it said do you have something
better to do you know and maybe that
that does change you over time I think
hmm well thanks for sharing that with us
and thanks for spending your time
especially here with us I mean I really
appreciate it
I enjoy it it's great to be out here get
out of here so rarely you know as much
as I love the greenness of North
Carolina
sometimes the smog of LA is a little
place to count right
yeah for sure well don't forget to show
your shirt oh yeah we was you know a big
Shakira fan shake your hips don't lie
yeah my heart will go on and it's just
holding is still beating bleeding hot
sexy stuff and a thank you to Dodger and
stripping that was a gift that they sent
oh I like it I'm like yeah I said I sent
them a box of weird [ __ ] at Christmas
and then I sent them another box as
their wedding gifts included like 17
rubber ducks and seven yodeling bacon
models so I think this is probably I
wouldn't say it's a revenge for that
because I really like this shirt yeah
thanks thanks to them for that it was a
was a nice thoughtful gift yeah they
know what I like
well once again
I think your your you've done a lot for
up good and you've inspired all of us
and I think I really appreciate you you
know I and thank you for coming in and
sharing your question yes that's been
great so thanks for watching everybody
appreciate you ha